Oh!
Hello everybody!
I said just finished earlier.
I was like just finished my food.
I ate too fast Sad news I ate too fast My tummy Says that
too But you just finish Oh, oh, it switches That's so fun
Oh, oh, it switches, that's so fun Welcome back to Deadly
Promonisha.
I don't know what at all to expect today at all.
Oh no, the consequences of your actions.
Okay, but it's because I could not eat sooner.
I was recording all day again.
Okay?
Well, not all day.
It was just a couple hours.
I was recording.
Until about an hour ago.
So...
Actually, when did I finish?
I don't remember.
Who knows?
Yeah, until an hour ago.
I'm tired of being in front of my computer a little bit.
Hmm.
But...
Just a little bit more recording tomorrow, and then I'll
be...
finished was it for our auto feeder yeah i've i've finished
recording the wolf among us today i finished playing that
it's really nice meeting you and then so too this week and
that was it oh also thank you for complimenting my kingsman
cosplay it's so funny oh my gosh thomas i've ever since so
i'm one of those people that has like a bunch of tabs open
on their on their um on their browser and ever since Vicky
told me about Kingsman I've had a tab open for it so that I
don't forget to watch it and so so I literally have been
like sometimes like I'll look at it and be like okay I want
to watch that sometime soon but it's not as many tabs as
you'd probably imagine it's just
oh dang I was gonna say less than 20.
It's not less than...
It's like 22.
I don't know about you.
I got 22.
Tabs open on my browser.
And they're all about you.
I'm on your profile.
I'm stuck in your page.
You don't post about Mickey today.
I'm gonna reach.
Thanks, you're always working so hard for us, Minto.
You're a real one.
Thank you, Maddie.
yeah i have a 20 i have only 22 but that's on firefox on
chrome i have a i have some more but i don't have that many
either it's just uh it's i just you watch a youtube and i
have um yeah i use two browsers because basically i don't
want to like log out of my YouTube channel to work on stuff
on my other channel.
You know what I mean?
Like when I work on stuff here, like on Minto channel, I
don't want to, like, I want to be watching other stuff
that's on my other, you know what I mean?
Yeah, the separation.
But the only other thing I know exactly what I have on
Chrome, and it's an eBay page for somebody that sells a
bunch of Metal Gear.
That sells a bunch of Metal Gear merch, and I always like
kind of look through and I'm like, Like, what do you have
today?
That's fair.
Yeah, I'm not just a crazy person that uses...
But also, sometimes you have to have, like, Chromium browser
because some sites don't like Firefox or whatever.
You know how it is.
But I don't really use Chrome.
What are you buying?
I haven't bought anything yet because their stuff is kind of
overpriced.
One day, what if either the prices go down or what if they
put something up that I, like, cannot refuse?
You know?
Dark Shmue, welcome back!
The cute ghost girl streaming this game with black hair.
Haven't we seen this before, Zach?
Hmm?
No, wait, did I have black hair before this last time I
played?
I don't think so.
La, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la,
la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, I did?
I don't remember.
I use Brave on my laptop, computer, and phone.
My phone, Firefox, is, like, ridiculous.
I have the Infinity tab.
You know, when you reach over 100 tabs, it's on Infinity.
I have a mobile.
browser that I use daily but it doesn't like the sponsored
links.
You have some time so I have another browser for that.
Just for the sponsor.
Susie Govaki!
Welcome back!
Thank you!
Vista, welcome back!
Thank you for two years!
I got the smiley face.
Wait, which is the smiley face?
Wait, which browser is that?
That's where all the tabs went.
I tried to keep my computer clean?
But my phone is just a mess.
Oh, it's Chrome!
I see, I see.
I probably should go through them.
I don't know.
Let's see.
What do I have open right now?
Oh, I have something about the Wolf Among Us.
I was trying to look up some of the fables.
I was like, know what these are so i was reading about them
i was like is this real is this real
oh my god
thank you look back you usually have the info in-game though
no well they were like you can read about them but i wanted
to know like the actual actual face And also, I think my,
it's not a gripe with the game, but they were like
introducing characters sometimes.
I mean, if you watch the playthrough, you'll see me talk
about it, but they would introduce a character.
But I guess maybe because I went a different route, I didn't
get the proper introduction of the character or something.
And I was just like, who is this?
Why are they involved?
I don't know anything.
Who is?
So.
But yeah, Deadly Premonition.
Um, who this?
Wait a second.
Who are you?
But Deadly Premonition, I don't know what's going on in this
game.
Oh, I need my screenshot of how to drive the car, don't I?
Wait a second.
Here it is.
My controls.
I have.
Fun, fun, fun, fun, fun, fun, fun, fun, fun, fun.
I'm assuming Wolf Among Us will get one video per episode.
Yep, you are assuming correctly.
So they're about a little over an hour each, which is kind
of nice, because usually, or the last time I did it, I did
an hour each, but they're a little over an hour.
Hmm.
Yes.
Are you going on holiday?
I wish it were holiday.
Not quite.
Morgan is basically a VTuber with his multitask skills,
right?
Francis York Minto.
My birthday is next week while you're out!
Planning to do karaoke with friends, any requests for an
off-the-wall song.
Rest in glitch phase!
Happy birthday!
Actually, plug your ears.
Plug your ears and then only listen to me say happy birthday
on your actual birthday.
York calls his chat, Zach.
Hey, Zach, are you seeing this?
Zach, are you seeing this?
Smart.
Plug your ears.
This is for birthday...
The birthday boy only.
We're all Zack down here.
Oh, karaoke request.
Um...
Karaoke request.
I don't know.
I definitely wasn't gonna do that anyway.
Good!
Dancing Queen.
You are the dancing queen.
Young and sweet, forever, 19.
Dancing queen.
As someone named Zach, I feel entitled to remain entirely in
your head.
Thank you, Zachary.
Actually, you are Zachary.
I'm on Team Zach.
I don't know what's going on.
So we have a murder.
In this town, in this small, small town.
We are back in Washington State.
And it is why so many spooky things happen here.
Twin Peaks.
It's like a, I guess like Twin Peaks created like a portal
or something.
A moida!
I'll do it.
I love Abba.
Thanks, Mickey.
Of course!
Yeah, we're solving a murder of a serial killer who leaves
petals in their victims.
And we have many of those, which means we are not doing a
very good job at catching this guy.
I think we maybe need to reassign the case to someone.
perhaps a little more competent.
I need like all of our wackadoo detectives to be in a room
together.
I need Hal again.
I need Nancy Drew, but specifically Nanashi Drew from the
RioCon.
I need York.
I need everybody to be together.
This is to be just Columbo.
Detective All Stars.
Alan Wake?
That guy's not a detective.
He's a rider.
Detective Conan.
Yeah, Columbo is, like, pretty competent, though.
That guy just acts kooky, you know.
Naaman?
Oh, wait.
Isn't that the guy from Heavy Rain?
Conan is also competent.
But, man.
I just want all of these like really strange detectives to
get I just honestly it's really just York and Halligan that
I need to see together I just want them to be like I want
them I want them to talk and discuss game plans and and evil
schemes Kogoro Mori needed okay yeah he can join Oh no, is
the guy that Conan puts to sleep in Detective Conan to like
solve the cases.
Janks?
Janks.
Wait, who's...
Wait, I know that name.
Who's Janks again?
Hope one day you meet Jonathan Ingram from Police Knots.
I feel like...
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah!
The pizza sauce never fails.
Talk detective.
If you went to check out a really great comedy set up with a
bunch of detectives trying to solve a murder, there's the
old movie called Murder by Death that I highly recommend.
Wait, that sounds so funny.
Oh, Janks!
Does this mean anything to you?
Yeah!
Yes!
Yes, Janks!
I was like, I know that name.
I know that name.
Oh, absolutely, Janks.
I was like, oh, I want to play more crazy, funny detective
games.
Send in Sherlock Schillingford now.
She got it.
The detectivers.
Heck, we can even have actual Sherlock in his mind palace.
We can do that.
New me for the island.
Thank you, Brandon!
I hope you're well too.
FK in the coffee.
Does this mean anything to you?
Cicil from Ghost Trick.
He's competent though.
I'm not trying to say these guys are not competent.
But...
I don't know how Halligan solved anything.
To be honest.
And this one...
So far, I'm not quite sure either what we're doing.
Gum shoe!
No, Halligan really didn't solve anything, did he?
York is very competent, just a bit strange.
Is that true?
Okay, okay.
We'll see, we'll see once we get more into the game.
Which shall we get more into the game?
Wow, I have so much money!
Let's resume.
We're profiling.
I'm doing much better.
Thank you.
Yumi!
Zenigata from Lupon.
Lupon!
Sam and Dean Winchester, they were kind of detectives.
Yeah, they were.
I feel like they are most needed here than anybody else,
maybe.
Because what is this case?
The Zets investigators?
Oh, they are very quirky.
True.
Or the one guy is, rather.
Would you like to restart with this file?
We're still on episode one.
Oh, sheesh.
These puppies are making me go to another town in the boot
dock.
The music won't stop.
Welcome to Green Woodland.
I can't hear you.
There's definitely something in this town.
Zach, do you feel it, Zach?
My coffee warned me about it.
I forgot about how bad the mixing is I apologize in advance
I feel like I've been having that issue lately with a lot of
games where it's like okay so we were going to uh how do I
this is how I run explain to me again oh let's head over to
the forest park then you're in charge now right i took over
because we determined that it is a uh it is a uh the fbi
case so all right let's get in the car everybody in
everybody in i beat pro transformers i know shut up me never
shut up oh if i could just give you a friendly warning are
you really upset about me taking over the case i can't get
over york's lip job though i have the authority like his
filler is insane command i understand you don't like it but
you will follow my orders i'm not disputing fbi authority
but this is our turn you won't get far alone and you gain
nothing by antagonizing me it's part of my personality i
just do things my way or the highway i can take you off the
case if you wish stop it you two yeah we need to solve this
case not bicker among ourselves yeah
I like it's so scary.
Boost.
Honk.
Okay.
Reverse.
Oh.
How do I go forward?
Accelerate.
Okay.
And there's blinkers and such.
How do I get out of this parking lot?
Don't mind me.
I'm going 10 miles per hour.
Okay.
I'm going to floor it.
Wait.
why did why did it get oh sorry excuse me oh gosh it's a
little uh it's a little it's a little um sensitive this is
my goal
oh game start wait what do you mean game start wait what's
happening oh
cherry blossoms wait what am i still are you still oh sorry
guys
i'm just getting used to the controls and all i'm not quite
sure what i'm doing here boost oh shoot oh oh shoot don't
worry about it oh Oh.
Oh.
Oh,
I've, how did I miss that?
Oh, shoot.
We're drifting.
Dorifto!
Wait, uh, there it is.
Okay, nice.
Wow, these brakes are awesome.
They work so well.
I didn't drift at all, but that's okay.
Oh, those are cars in the way.
Oh my gosh.
You turn, you turn.
How many of these do I need to do before time out?
Are we wasting time doing this?
Wait, is this not a road?
Oh.
Where's the road, actually?
Ah!
Oh, we're just back here.
It's integral to the investigation that I finished this race
I imagined around Greenvale.
George.
Isn't that right, Zach?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Um, anyway.
Don't worry about why we were doing that.
I was just trying to get out of here.
I don't actually know how to leave.
Oh, no.
No, I can't get a second chance.
Oh, yes, I can.
Just kidding.
But we should probably leave, right?
Oh, here we go.
Sorry.
Get out of the way.
Bushes are in my way.
All right, everyone.
I'm going to teach you how to properly drive.
Look.
One more pass.
Look?
Okay, turn.
Floor it.
Out of the way!
Official business!
Oh, shoot.
Uh, my bad.
Uh, one second.
Gosh,
these dang kids.
Stay on the proper side of the road.
A week ago.
fishing wait what time do we have until uh hold on look
while you're turning backwards okay oh talk yeah hannah's
body was discovered by the weekend jim green along with his
two grandchildren isaac and isaiah what were they doing in
the forest just their daily routine oh wait but if we get
out they're gonna leave us aren't they so you've talked i
want to talk to them more not officially not yet not yet are
you out of your mind you haven't interviewed them yet agent
york that tone is hardly appropriate we were given orders to
wait for you to arrive orders by who a man called abrams
from the fbi robert is it called bob abrams i did tell him
to stay out of it sorry it's a little sensitive thank
goodness she doesn't fly airplanes am i right we may not
have taken official statements but we got all the
information we need i can fill you in right now if you'd
like thanks oh safe we rolled right back into position I
just can't believe that the children had to witness the
crime scene.
They may be traumatized.
You'd better do this carefully.
Don't tell me you get nervous talking to children, Emily.
Not at all.
That's not what I meant.
Then what did you mean?
Just forget it.
Oh my gosh, my steering wheel is just so sensitive.
Oh, do I turn here?
I think so.
I wonder...
Never mind.
Okay, the game says you can't take a shortcut.
Out of the way!
Oh, uh, when you're passing someone, put your blinker on.
I'm glad they gave you a clue to my favorite punk song.
Uh, our...
Manian imbecile.
Wait, am I going the right way?
Oh, yeah, we are.
Good, good, good.
Oh, excuse me.
Oh, sorry, that's a...
Oh, wait, this is not a road.
Uh, shoot.
Well, um...
Where are we?
Hmm.
Maybe we can drive, uh, go up this way.
Nope.
Uh, hmm.
Hmm, mm-hmm.
Okay, uh... Oh, here we go.
Here's the road.
Oh.
Not bad.
Okay.
Uh, so close.
They didn't use their blinker.
Wait, oh, I think I'm going the wrong way.
Good turn.
Oh no, I'm gonna run out of gas!
Wait, hey, was someone honking at me?
Uh, excuse me, this is police business.
I had my blinker on.
Map in the menu.
Title?
Oh, here we go.
Oh, there's a card here!
And a card here.
Uh, where are we going?
Uh...
There's so many cards!
Oh, is that a restroom?
Milk barn!
Uh, I'm off.
We're fine.
We can figure it out.
What is this place anyway?
It looks like a jungle gym or something.
Oh, I think it's a power thing.
Oh, oops, wrong way.
Oh, oh, turn the wheel.
Come on, York.
Oh, here we are.
We made it.
We're so close.
We're doing it.
My gas is at 73%.
You think they'll pay for it, like, a little bit?
Or...
Mito, I found a gun!
No!
Extra for long distance.
Well, I mean, it's not my fault that this place is so
freaking far.
Whoa!
Oh, we're getting a little feel for the town.
Gas money.
Yeah, exactly.
This map is humongous.
My bad.
Back at you, buddy.
I can't tell if I'm supposed to be like...
Oh, this is a railroad.
Wrong way.
There we go.
Oh yeah, silly combos, yeah.
How much longer do you want to keep talking?
Maybe we should cut the chit-chat and go get our official
statements.
George is right.
Let's head over to the forest park.
I'm working on it.
I can't tell if they want me to actually go all the way over
here?
Or like...
If I should be stopping at some places in between or
something.
This is crazy.
This is so far.
Oh.
here?
Where are we?
Oops.
Oh,
I got a metal.
Oh, wait.
That's not letting me collect the metals.
Oh, I got one.
Am I close?
Yeah, we're getting closer.
Oops.
We're almost there.
Don't mind it.
Okay, one time.
If this isn't a road, why is it road-shaped?
Mint can't drive.
What are you talking about?
I'm literally getting us there on One Piece!
One second.
There was a bit of a...
There we go.
We're fine.
And there's so many money things here.
We gotta go.
Oh.
Sorry.
I should...
I'm paying attention to the road.
I promise.
Uh, one second?
Are you guys getting dizzy at all?
Even though I'm controlling it, I'm getting dizzy.
Eyes on the road.
I don't even need to look because the walls guide me.
I could close my eyes.
See, the walls are guiding me, so I don't even need to look.
And we're back on the road!
Did I pass it?
Oh, no, we're almost there.
We're almost there.
Oh my god, we made it.
Stinking whole gas tank.
Shows you're a roller coaster girl.
Watch the road.
I don't need to.
Oh.
What is he doing?
Is this government land?
No, it's private.
owned by harry this whole area oh it's gone thank you this
whole area is owned by harry i'm sure i mentioned that he
owns pretty much the whole town oh yeah there's that weird
guy with the mask to buy up most of the town many town
residents live on his land zach did you hear that this
entire park zach a rich man's personal playground these
country rich folk are amazing zach did you hear that it all
looks very well kept too it does Zach, did you hear that?
Oh, the tree.
I'm FBI Special Agent Francis York Morgan.
Please call me York.
That's what everyone calls me.
And you are Jim Green?
That I am, son.
I keep these woods.
Jim Green.
Well, you're doing a fine job.
Well, I used to be a tree surgeon.
A tree surgeon?
And these two...
What?
They're nodding.
It's like in sync.
Hello, I am Isaac Ingram.
And I am Isaiah Ingram.
Why are they so scary?
Zach, you see that?
Twins.
Just like in my dream.
What?
We got to keep in mind.
Oh, yeah.
You're in mind palace.
I'm sorry.
Could we talk away from the boys?
Percy, welcome back to Memoos.
Thank you.
want them to hear this very well emily and please i'll just
take them over there then thank you yes emily don't do
anything without take us over there these children were the
first to witness the crime scene i want to talk to them come
on they're just kids they have no idea it stands don't crap
don't don't don't even look at them you agree with me right
sack how hardless do you ever think of other people's
feelings ever emily's right she's falling for You can tell.
Even for the sake of investigation.
She's like, he's so aloof.
They may have seen something we adults would never spot.
And they are here at our request as well.
We could at least chat with them and see if they want to
make a statement.
Are you serious?
I never joke about matters like this.
Don't smile.
Ew, it's so creepy.
Don't worry.
They aren't as fragile as you think.
We're not fragile.
as we have each other I'm looking around oh now then down
I'm looking around Isaiah tell me what did you find here
Anna she was so pretty she had a red dress on her hair was
shining bright gold hair there were lots of animals around
her squirrel weasel and a snake a real snake we didn't know
until then but we know now forest she was a goddess she
smiled when she saw us she looks so happy that's right Isaac
Isaiah she was a fairy she was a fairy I'm sure she is why
am I able to look around to be honest yeah of course why am
I able to look around was I not well Emily you can take them
now that was it she was a fairy
uh-oh okay zach this is where anna's body was and that means
our unsub our unknown subject was here too so our unsub hold
on let me define that for you our unknown subject does his
lighter have a no smoking thing on it profiling start don't
unsub answer to anything.
Anna.
The subtitles and the audio is out of sync.
Zach, something is still missing.
We need more clues.
It's so quiet.
Zach, I'm not getting anything from my...
Oh!
From my coffee.
Come on, man.
What is this in here?
here oh i can sleep in here i'm observing i can definitely
get some sleep here zach huh what do we got what is this who
wait picture of a vest with holes a picture in a place like
this oh you got picture of a vest with holes okay oh i'm
profiling Do I have to do this every time?
Or should I just wait until I get all the keys?
Is that better?
I mean, not better, but like...
Just wait.
Okay.
Crap!
You can skip it.
Okay.
It does have like the timer, so it kind of, you know...
I guess you get extra money.
Hello, George.
There's a human bug!
bone over here?
Uh...
One second, I'll get it.
The human bone?
Nobody seems to be worried about it.
Oh no!
No, my bone!
No, no my bone!
What is this?
Is there another way around?
Oh, oh, that's right!
I can break them!
Thank you guys!
I completely forgot.
Wait, what?
Yay!
I completely forgot.
What is this?
A can of pickles!
Thank you.
Official business.
Obviously.
And then, other side, other side.
Let me get the human bone.
Yeah.
Wait, where is it?
Oh, I don't like the lightning.
It's scary.
Oh, oops.
Huh.
Where is Emily?
I only see George.
Oh.
What was the point of coming up here?
Okay, nothing.
Great.
It's too spooky.
All right.
Well, we have whatever.
As you requested, we have permission to stay and look around
as needed.
What are you planning on doing?
To examine the scene, of course.
Basic crime investigation 101.
Cover some further up.
Do you need an umbrella?
I might have covered this already.
I seriously doubt that there is anything else to find.
Well, then you and Emily can wait in the car if that's the
case.
Hmm, I beg to differ by the glowing light by the tree.
Does this mean anything to you?
Zach, look, the depression on the grass.
I think we have a clue.
You got two bent pieces of grass.
Two bent pieces of grass.
Oh, yeah, baby.
I'm observing.
Anna's body was found hanging from this tree.
Why did the murderer bother to hang the dead body, I wonder?
Two whole grass.
A clue.
Definitely not made by anybody else.
Wait.
Now there's like a...
Is it in here?
There's a...
A thing.
No.
Oh!
In the tree!
Uh...
Wait, how do I get that?
Wait, how...
Can I jump?
Wait...
There's something in the...
In the bird's nest!
There's a car...
Oh, I can shoot it!
Oh!
Uh, you guys are so smart.
Oh, wait, hold on.
Let me move a little further away.
Oh!
Ha-ha-ha-ha!
Do-do-do!
Ana!
Add this to my trading card collection.
Yes.
Oh!
She made two?
Plus two!
$100!
Uh, wait, there's something here too.
Why is there, why is there so much evidence in these bird
nests?
Chow!
Missing piece of pin heel shoe.
Oh!
Okay.
Evidence.
The birds are guilty.
Here, I'll profile, profile.
Profiling?
start i feel like i'm a oh oh it's the guy
amazing yamaguchi naked snake figure yet no i haven't
oh crap cheese like cheese scoop like crap scoop i haven't
been ordering many figures because i'll be moving and i
don't know where i'm moving to yet so it's kind of like uh
oh let's focus on the investigation okay i don't want to
order anything and then it comes and I'm not haunting that
place anymore.
Are these more pickles?
Unlimited pickle works?
Hmm.
Was there...
Did anything form up here?
Wait, maybe we could get a better look?
Ah!
Right there!
More birds!
More birds.
Oh, how convenient.
Chip with rusted metal dust.
Very smart.
Thank you.
Oh.
All right, the final profiling piece.
I haven't seen one of these in a long time.
It's upside down.
Wait, why did it stopped raining?
I guess this is meant to be an anti-peace sentiment.
No, peace, peace.
Please hold.
on the ground we're made by uh why is the music and this
depression why this song i see what happened here i'll come
from the tree put on her shoes it's really it has no no
reason disgusting disgusting do do do going on in and York's
head.
George, you certainly have a vivid imagination.
What?
An interesting theory.
Don't you think, Zach?
I don't know if she's actually...
What was his name again?
That Hollywood producer.
Which one?
That's right.
Joel.
Joel?
We really ought to introduce George to him.
What are you mumbling to yourself over there, York?
Terrence, you know.
His profiling is a little different from writing a
screenplay, though.
An idea being interesting.
doesn't make it fact.
Joe Mama?
Let me invite you, George.
The footprints reveal that one of the heels were missing
from the shoes.
And they're different from Anna's shoes that we saw in the
audience.
The out-of-place music playing over a crime scene
investigation is called Life is Beautiful.
There would be even more disgusting evidence if he did kneel
and, well, do as you suggested.
Oh, finally.
If you want proof, go ahead and try it for yourself.
a reason other than simple perversion.
To pray.
Zach, what was he doing in front of Anna?
He was, I don't know, profiling start!
There he is.
Anna, Anna.
Anna.
What an awful way to die.
Life is beautiful.
Intensivize.
I hate this.
Oh, crap.
Oh, geez.
What?
Oh, I knew it!
Oh, my gosh.
I should replace York.
It was like the twins said.
She was a fairy.
By the way, did you know Unsub means...
unknown subject and not unsub to my YouTube channel in fact
you should do the opposite you should subscribe to my
YouTube channel so miss stiletto heels the steps are close
coming up to the body and then farther apart going away
there was a reason to hurry away then that settles it then
George miss stiletto heels is a third party here she's not
the murderer no one runs away from an object of worship.
What?
What do you mean by that?
He could be another victim who was with Anna.
Spank, thank you so much for the thank you three!
Who fled for some reason.
I'ma play life as beautiful at my funeral.
He is also one who took whatever it was Anna was holding on
to in her hand.
George is pretending to be a bird.
Why did she leave her here?
He's flapping his arms.
Oh, Miss Stiletto Heels is such a...
You might know something about the man with a reversed piece
mark, too.
Bum bum bum bum bum bum bum bum bum bum.
How many women wear high stiletto heels in this town do you
think?
Oh, I should think most of them have at least one pair.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
I do too, before you ask.
But nobody would...
I don't own any stiletto heels.
Except...
Well, except maybe one person.
don't keep me in the dark then who might this can't whistle
today diane the owner of the art gallery but she's out of
town for a big art auction i heard she'll be coming back in
a couple days i heels are bad for your feet are they i
imagine so but a more immediate matter then i want some
barbie where in town can you find something like this what
is that it should be a building that is used anymore with
either a lot of metal or metal machinery or something like
that the old lumber mill it's time to really get this show
on the road could you guide me to this perfect setting for
extravagant murder okay
is this Scooby-Doo?
Yay!
Okay.
Let's give me my cash money, baby.
Dang!
We're making so much in just a day.
Yes, let's save.
Vid games.
Liverville is pretty far from here.
If that's where she was killed...
Wait, from here?
Why would the killer go to all the trouble carrying her all
the way here?
Well, I was thinking like...
I don't know yet.
my profiling instincts tell me one thing is i have to drive
there the unsub's personality is totally different before
and after the crime the unsub means brutal what does unsub
mean and then displays powerful adoration after she's dead
something close to someone explain it could well be the key
to all this i will say this though george unknown subject is
a risky oh okay of course if the unsub planted those what
does unsub mean well then everything I've just said falls
apart.
But there's no evidence that he left those stiletto
footprints.
Unsubscribe to some subject.
No!
Don't unsub.
In light of the evidence.
And carefully figure that you...
I'll never make it to 4-4-4.
Modus operandi.
His way of thinking.
He usually unveils something that a normal forensic analysis
may overlook.
That's my way of...
He was looking right into the camera.
Oh, he's still looking.
It's not for everyone, but it works for me.
Excuse me, my favorite quirky game ever?
Let's go!
Yeah!
Okay, I definitely was not paying attention at all.
My bad.
We're going to the murder site.
Oops, I'm...
All right, how far away is it?
Okay.
It's a little far, guys.
Buckle up.
Wait, what's in here?
I don't want to get out of the car.
Oh, it's closed.
Okay.
I like the driving simulator.
I'm not sure if you want to endorse this lumber mill.
This is killing full swing.
when i first moved here oh that's so bright i can't see it
oh oh god i need glasses oh we're fine everything's fine
we're back on the road deserted buildings are perfect for
criminal hideouts and activities i can tell harry to have
the place torn down probably after all wheel drive baby some
of the vana's murder don't know that for sure yet agent
morgan but that's right but the perpetrator selected the
lumberman agent morgue he seemed very confident about this
oh sorry oh we're fine that was so smooth that sounds
exactly like being full of confidence you know what unsub
means but you know that Jaeger is German for hunter what
never heard that we're getting closer guys we're getting
closer wait what about my gas though it's now it doesn't
show a percentage anymore.
I'm hurrying.
You got it, pretty lady.
I think I'm going the right way.
Yeah.
Wait, what is this?
A flower?
We could get out of the car for a flower.
We could get out of the car for a flower!
If I get out, will they get mad at me and say, we're not
gonna go?
B to get out of car.
Get out of car.
Maybe I need to get in the grass.
B to get out of car.
B.
What's wrong, Zach?
Let's get this investigation going.
Oh, uh...
What my flower?
Oh, it's a scripted drive.
Oh, okay.
Is that maybe why we don't have gas and everything, too?
That makes sense.
Boo!
We just can't get out of the car because of the child safety
locks.
Wee-wee-wee-wee-wee-wee-wee-wee-wee.
official business going on.
Everybody out of the way!
I'm coming through!
I'm a police officer, detective FBI!
Yeah, this is a dramatic moment, truly.
Oh.
Let's go.
Find out if your backs can be trusted.
You're full of confidence, right?
Let's get to the lumber mill.
Floor it.
Let me in, please.
No, I don't think we should, I don't think we should, uh, we
probably shouldn't, uh, race again.
How do I get in here, though?
Is this our road?
No?
Oh, I see, I see.
We gotta go through here.
And around.
Do I do karaoke after my birthday dinner?
Last night it was great.
We had an evening.
Mic-mac!
Thank you!
Happy birthday.
What did you get for birthday dinner?
Wait, there's a car here.
I thought this place was abandoned.
Not bad.
Italian?
Yummy!
I'm going in alone.
Uh-oh.
You two stay here.
I can't concentrate on profiling with other people around
me.
Hold on a minute.
We're investigating this case together.
I don't think that's wise.
Listen, I can't risk the crime scene being compromised by
you two.
What are you saying?
You're not the only professional law enforcement officer
here, Agent Morgan.
We know how to secure a crime scene.
I'm sorry.
That was rude of me.
But this is how I operate.
furthermore yes furthermore what to me the outsider FBI
agent every citizen of this town is a suspect you two could
be in on this whole thing for all I have to keep suspects
out of the crime scene how can you say such a thing gasp is
he making fun of us she's so cute behind and come here by
ourselves you're right you're right I've never been so
insulted sorry but I'm just doing my job sorry but I'm just
doing my job.
Wait, York, we should go get the...
Oh, never mind.
I was going to say we should go get the, uh...
What's it called?
There was a, uh...
A card.
Wait, but the spooky guys are going to come out in here,
aren't they?
That, Zach?
If they are pros, then we should let every first-person
shooter gamer out there join the SWAT team.
Uh-oh.
Yep, it's happening.
It's happening!
Zach, they're here.
Ugh.
No, no.
no because the police officer suspects wouldn't have already
tampered with the crime scene that's what I was thinking
right spooky guys are in here I knew it why can't we go in
together I'm spooked I'm scared what is this place why does
it look like this oh thank you so much for the tiny Can I
get the thank you?
Ugh.
Oh my goodness.
Oh, okay.
Ring.
Oh my gosh, please.
Don't want to die.
I thought I had auto-aim on this thing.
Oh shoot.
I thought I had it.
Don't want to do...
Like, I thought...
Oh, wait.
Then it turned off.
Oh!
Where'd she go?
There she is.
Like, I thought when I...
Oh, oh, oh.
There we go.
Oh, oh.
Holy cow.
Okay.
Can't use this anyway.
Oh, okay, actually.
Okay.
It's fine.
We'll get rid of a steel pipe eventually, probably.
Yeah, very spooky.
Very scary.
Don't want to die.
Oh, we can break this, though.
And hi-ya.
And nothing.
Toolbox it?
You're right.
Let's go put it in our toolbox.
Toolbox.
Thank you?
Nope.
Oh, oh, I accidentally observed it.
There we go.
Okay.
Don't...
I thought, though, I had...
like a an auto aim thing on it's just so it's such a
sensitive you know it's so sensitive all right i have to
catch or check every
oh there's multiple of them oh uh don't watch it all that's
not a bullseye buddy wait did i kill him oh i guess i did i
guess that worked Don't want to die.
Yes.
Oh.
Don't want to die.
Oh, did I kill him?
Yeah.
I wish I could move and like walk and aim at the same time.
Yes.
There he is.
Come on.
Oops.
What did I just... Oh.
Where?
Him?
Yes.
Oh.
No.
Don't hear another.
Check your corners.
Where is he?
I don't want to get ambushed.
Is he right behind me?
He sounds behind me.
Is it in here?
No?
Where is...
Uh...
Hello?
What?
Okay.
Why is this so loud?
You kind of like chuckle sometimes too.
Oh,
come on.
Oh, just kidding.
I was going to say, why is it?
I'm never given anything.
That's Zach.
Zach just hasn't had his snack yet.
Oh, what's that sound?
What was that?
Wait, who is it?
Can I get this guy?
Maybe not.
Is that our guy?
Oh, that might be our guy!
I think that might be the killer.
Does my health get lower from driving?
I wonder.
QTE time?
I sure hope not.
Don't make me do it, please.
Just as I thought so.
This is where Ana was killed.
Oh my god.
It looks like a boss place.
Uh oh.
I did crash a few times.
I haven't had to heal yet.
I mean, I could.
Don't want to die.
Oh, my profiling?
Oh.
Hey!
Come here.
Ooh, she's flirting with me, I think maybe.
This one's long!
Holy cow!
Were they freaking in the abandoned lumber mill?
Thank you so, thank you so much for the thank you!
That's just asking for tetanus.
Dang this one's really long.
Are those teeth?
It's the cigarette of insight.
Too much noise.
We're still missing a vital piece of the puzzle.
Okay.
Well, you just got in here, buddy.
He took one...
One puff...
And then I was just like, nah, I think I'll go with this.
Oh.
We got locked out.
Rutt roll.
What is this?
A submachine gun!
Okay, thank you.
Uh, sure?
Huh.
Curious.
Zach, it's almost like an altar.
Why is it wiggling like that?
Was the murder some kind of ritual?
What is that?
Why was it wiggling?
Why was it wiggling like that?
Oh, this looks like an area with a lot of guys.
Oh, there's money down here though.
Oh, what's down there?
Wait.
Oh, okay, hold on.
So there's a door down there, but there's also up here.
Both are lit up, so I wonder which one we go to.
Let's go to this one first, because it does seem like we
need to go to the bottom one, too.
Oh, there's stuff in here!
And another door down there, question mark?
20 bucks is 20 bucks.
I mean, I'll take it.
I find $20.
Oh, shoot.
Wait, why is it like that?
Is this not a safe room?
We can sleep in here.
Is it not safe?
Oh, I'll take a smoked salmon.
Absolutely.
On a platter and everything.
It's a danger room.
Hello?
Anti-peace.
Oh no!
You got reversed peace sign.
Who?
Oh, dang it, I didn't mean to profile.
That's okay though.
Who was...
Phone.
The fishnets and everything.
I can't quite tell what's going on in that one.
Come here.
Hi.
Oh.
That was also the reverse peace sign.
They're kissing!
I heard it!
And also...
Oh no, she's crying!
Kiss of death?
Let me, uh, also save.
Bada-dum.
Nice.
Oh, we could shave.
What is here?
Lollipop will take it.
Thank you.
We could sleep.
Oh, we can toolbox.
We could change.
I want to wait until I get gross, though.
what would happen.
Wait, can't I, like, check the other ones?
No?
It won't let me open anything out.
Okay, whatever.
Um, open?
Key to the engineering section.
I'll take that.
Thank you.
You must get the key to progress before we allow you to
progress.
Okay.
They're like, we won't let you soft-lock the game on
accident.
You must get the thing you need first, then we'll let you
go.
And something, I don't know.
Okay, cool.
Uh-oh, there's a baddie down there.
What do you say?
Ah!
Oh my god!
Holy!
Where'd you come from?
Ah!
Yes!
Don't kill me.
Scared me.
He's dead, right?
Okay, good.
Oh, you scared me.
I didn't know he was right behind me!
Are they teleporting?
Oh, there's another guy over here too.
Need to get him in the head.
Where else?
Don't want to die.
Is there a guy behind me again?
No, okay.
Ugh.
I'll take the money.
Thank you.
30 bucks.
Let's go.
Can I take this?
Do you have the machine gun?
Oh, I do!
Yeah.
Uh...
Which would be better?
Probably, like, walking down there, right?
I could get the money, too.
Do you want to see me?
See what happens when I use the machine gun on these guys.
Oh, there he is.
Hold on.
I casually am walking away.
Where did he go?
Yes.
it hurts oh that's what he's saying it hurts they're all
like camping down there hold on let's go up here get them
from up here i don't know i feel like my regular gun is
pretty this is not bad it's so loud
don't walk to die why did they have a british attacks,
though, when they say it.
Don't.
Ugh.
I don't see the last guy.
I also...
I don't think I...
Oh, there he is.
Get him.
Get him before.
Dang it.
No, no.
Don't go into the corner.
Don't go over there.
Oh, wait.
We can still get him, though.
That's good.
Perfect.
There we go.
I wonder if...
Oh, there's another guy.
That was good.
Thank you.
Great.
Oh, shh.
Are they...
Are they gonna keep coming?
I mean...
I wonder if they're like the...
Let me do...
I thought you don't want to die.
Which is it?
Let me die or don't want to die.
Oh, yeah, I'll take that.
Oh, just kidding.
Uh, we'll toolbox it then?
Toolbox it.
He studied the crowbar.
Oh, yeah, they're infinite, aren't they?
Oh, man.
Hmm.
Sorry, buddy.
Bullseye.
Yes.
Oh, you're still coming at me?
Wait, I thought you were...
Amazing.
Thank you.
Get the goodies and run out quick, I think so.
Run!
Get the money!
Get the cash!
Go, go, go!
Oh.
Amazing.
Nice.
Oh, there's...
This guy's coming down.
Oh, no, he forgot about me.
He's fine.
Yeah!
I got a bar!
Better than a crowbar!
Or a pipe?
Maybe better than the steel pipe.
We'll switch that out then later.
Wait.
Is it unlimited pipe?
Cool, whatever.
Okay.
Engine room.
Open.
Is there going to be a boss in here?
What was that?
What is this?
Some sort of liquid?
Liquid.
It's rusted all over.
Won't budge without a good whacking.
Any tools handy, Zach?
Well, as a matter of fact, I can whack it.
Why is it so quiet?
Oh, wow!
That's the fastest drain!
Also, that was so much liquid.
That might have been the fastest drain I've ever seen ever.
That was crazy.
Do you think there's guys down here now?
Or...
How do I heal myself?
I'm gonna check my thing real quick.
Oh, here maybe.
Bandage.
Use?
Okay, good, good, good.
There we go.
Can we eat food, right?
What if I try eating my pickles?
A small amount of my hunger.
Oh, my hunger is my hunger.
I'm guessing I get hit.
Like, or rather I take...
I take more...
Or less damage when I...
Let's see.
When I'm less hungry, I imagine.
Small amount of hunger.
Here, I'll eat the pickles.
Oh, nice.
Nice, that was good.
I did eat a lot.
I had an egg.
Can I walk in this?
Oh, okay.
I had an egg and a can of pickles and a lollipop, a cup of
lollipop.
Jesus.
Holy cow, that lady scared me.
Holy yeah.
I didn't see her at all.
I was too busy talking about my dinner.
I'm up there.
I saw it.
Yes.
The peace.
I'm observing it.
A huge upside down peace mark.
Peace mark's been drawn on the steam engine tank.
Any idea what it means, Zach?
Anti-peace.
Hey.
Oops, uh, awkward.
Don't let him.
Yes.
Oh, coming from the walls.
Coming from the walls.
Oh, I'm running.
I'm leaving?
Nasty sound.
What's this?
What is this?
No comment?
On the ooze?
Wait, no comment?
Okay, that's fine.
I don't care about it either.
Oh, they're like roots or something.
Huh.
I hear a baby.
Oh my gosh, I can't get a...
Can't get a hit at all.
I hear a baby.
Can I just hear the baby?
Can I tell it to stop?
It's like baby recording.
Baby recording.
Anything in here?
Any pickles I can have?
My pop's gonna break soon.
Hooyah!
I can't tell if I'm in the baby room or not.
It's like...
Open up.
Oh!
You guys, did you know there was a...
Did you know there was a golf club in there?
Who stole?
How did they store it in there like that?
What the heck?
So funny.
Just for a golf club?
I mean, sure.
Movie magic, truly.
I'm feeling magical.
Is the baby in here?
The baby sounds like it might be in here.
Oh, it's cute.
Baby?
Baby in the toilet?
Oh, we're flushing the baby.
Uh-oh.
No!
Goodbye, baby!
Uh.
What the?
Uh-oh.
Rutt roll.
I don't know what that meant.
I think we flushed his baby.
Nothing of any interest to me.
There's Idaho potato chips, maybe, or something.
Finally peace!
No!
The baby!
This is like a crazy bathroom though.
How is it so overgrown?
Like how does so much plant happen in here?
I don't see anything else.
Oh shoot.
Nice shot.
Do I need to keep taking these?
Oh, I meant...
I did press Y.
Oh, we don't have any more room in our inventory.
I was able to take the golf club.
Okay, that's good, though.
Where are you?
Just walk over here.
Come on.
Are you on my left?
Zombo on my left?
Yep.
Zombo on my right?
No.
His delayed reaction.
Oh, this is where he ran out.
Oh, gosh.
He, like, kicked it open.
I don't want to...
I don't want to QTE, please.
I don't want to die!
Oh
my gosh.
Bullseye.
Maybe I should get my machine gun ready.
I'm guessing we can't vault over this.
Oh yes we could!
I'll do it.
Oh yeah!
There's a guy like right there.
I can get him real quick.
Watch this.
Yes.
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
Watch this.
Watch.
You're watching?
Why?
We'll go through here.
Oh, but I need my pipe.
My trusty pipe.
Oh, there's cash in here.
Oh.
Remind me, we can't do anything else.
So we had to go this way.
We're watching.
Check this out.
Shoot us fast.
Amazing.
Amazing, he says.
Oh!
I hear another baby?
Oh my gosh.
I hear another baby.
What did you do up?
Oh.
Yeah, I want the new, like, instead of the steel bars, we'll
start collecting the other bars.
My bar?
I got bars?
Can't get through this rubble.
We'll have to find another way, Zack.
Yes, Zack!
I hear another bivy.
Keep dry.
Oh, I could push them though.
Looks like I can move this.
It's up to you, Zach.
Or we could smash it.
Nice.
Let's keep my machine gun.
Open?
Oh, peek?
I don't like the looks of that.
Oh, there's so many parts!
There's so many parts!
There's so many places where things will...
will spawn from!
The zombie goo!
Oh man!
They're like, hey, I got an observation menu.
No!
I mean, I'm the baby crying about having to go through this.
Heck yeah.
Hold your breath.
Can I do that?
The baby is in here.
Everything will be alright.
I don't remember how to hold my breath though.
Was it this?
Oh, it was this.
What is it?
A gear box.
Gear.
Uh-oh.
No!
The game hates me.
Oh, there.
Um.
I see boxes over there.
I wonder if I can go around that way.
Okay, hold on.
Who's flushing the toilet?
Wait, actually.
Oh, my God.
Ah!
Shoot.
Oh.
Uh.
Ah!
No!
Get him!
Hey, yeah!
Oh.
Wait, what's wrong with me?
Get him!
Oh, shoot.
I think I do actually have to kill these guys.
Oh, please.
Oh, shoot.
Yes.
Amazing.
Bullseye.
Nice.
Yeah.
I think?
Uh, let's go back to my other gun.
Wait, no.
There we go.
Yeah.
She's a little slow.
Amazing.
Yes.
Okay, we're fine.
I forgot this idiot crawls.
Because I thought maybe I had to destroy these to then,
like, go another way.
I don't know.
I don't...
Whatever.
It's fine.
My honor.
Okay.
Don't want to die.
Okay, good.
I was gonna say, what about these ones though?
Nobody behind me?
Two of them.
Two of them, two of them, two of them.
And...
Oh!
Two of them?
None of them.
Nothing of interest.
I feel like it's kind of taken a little joke on, like,
horror game...
where, uh...
full of murky water, a sickly blackish red color.
Like, horror games where you have to, like, reach the
toilets for keys and stuff.
Oh!
Thank you.
I don't know why the toilet paper looks like that.
It's a little horrifying.
This is where the other guy came out, right?
Ooh, why is it blinking?
Don't...
Oh.
Is that a...
Is that a moldy wall?
Goopy?
Goo wall.
I could run.
They'll start coming out in three, two, one.
One.
and a half.
Point half?
One.
Just kidding.
Red or blue paper?
Green.
Always bet on green.
Okay, I feel like we're probably gonna have to run back
through here and deal with a bunch of guys as we run.
Probably.
Always bet on green.
You know what?
What did we just run?
Okay, anyway.
Are they following me?
No.
They don't care.
Oh!
Oh my god!
Big man!
Oh, he's doing the limbo!
I am the 90s.
I am the limbo man from the 90s.
Oh, here, another guy.
There is.
Oh, there he is.
Wait.
Oh, shoot.
It's just showing his special skill.
Okay.
I'll take that, thank you!
King of Limbo.
Oh, I love root.
A coffee!
Black coffee Let's go Good evening, Mint Good evening
Okay And climb up And climb down And Wiggle around Yes Yes
She did Oh Stop Stop wiggling so much.
Thank you.
Let me get you in the head.
Shoot.
Oh, shoot.
Hold on.
Great.
Oh, so glad that we...
that nothing bad happened there.
He was so kind to just let us reload in front of him.
Is this also open?
Okay, no.
I'm just wasting my pipe, I think.
Don't want to die.
Would you kindly...
We could go this way?
I'm assuming we have to after I...
Do whatever is this.
Let's see what this is first.
It's important.
Turn on?
There's some machinery behind the elevator.
It has power, alright.
motor does our gearbox our gearbox okay okay hi yeah our
metal gear observe can't get through the rubble wait wait
what is up oh money money money it's just within reach.
Come on.
You work.
Lift your legs.
York!
Maybe I can defeat it.
Oh, my pipe!
Oh, good.
I pull one.
I pull another from my hammer space.
Heya!
Like, I don't think it's worth it.
Shoot the barrels?
I learned a new thing.
Got it.
Oh, geez.
Okay.
I understand.
Oh!
Oh.
I guess I could go...
Nice.
When in doubt, kaboom.
I didn't...
I don't know what to expect.
Somebody behind here.
Anybody?
Somebody ready to ambush me!
No.
Let's put in our gearbox.
In...
I like how it's just...
Wait.
It's just a giant, like, rectangle.
And we just assume that putting it in there will make...
It doesn't even attach to anything.
Like, it would just...
The gear fits the recess like a glove.
We should be able to move the elevator now.
Is there anybody?
Anybody come back out?
I guess not.
Insert the rectangle.
Alright.
Bip.
Where are we going?
This is the strangest lumberyard ever, no?
La la la la la.
Actually, I mean I'm going to heal real quick, though.
Just in case.
We're going to heal.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's good.
This place is huge.
It really is.
I don't know how it's abandoned.
I...
Are you there?
Of course.
Oh my gosh.
This looks just like the...
Oh, are you serious right now?
Peak?
This looks like the beginning of MGS of Metal Gear.
Like when he's in the elevator.
Oh, what am I doing?
That doesn't seem very safe.
Wait, this seems really bad.
What are we reaching into?
Why is it slimy?
Ew, red hair?
Oh, damaged red hair.
I could profile!
Oh, I only have two.
I thought I had all four.
We'll wait, we'll wait.
Yeah, but now...
Yeah, things are gonna get started.
Oh, man.
Snake, get out of there.
There's four guys on that elevator.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, okay.
Nice.
La, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la.
Oh.
Looks like the power is out.
We'll need to restore power to move this elevator, Zach.
Yay.
Goody-y-y.
Oh, that definitely doesn't look like a trap.
Like, I wonder if there's anyone down that corridor.
Surely not.
Okay.
Take it.
Shirley, why are you guys saying that?
In conspicuous hallway, exactly.
Oh, what is this?
Oh, another bar.
Yeah, I'll take it.
Alright, top secret.
The motor looks intact, it might move again, providing we
restore power.
Okay, okay.
Why couldn't the three of us come in here is my question.
Oh, nice!
We can save!
Nice!
Nice, nice.
I was hoping we would get a save.
Wait, does that mean we're about to do a big old boss
battle?
Big old something?
Oh, what is that?
Wait.
Oh.
Okay.
Maybe?
Not nearly.
As bad as I thought.
It's the infinite lollipops.
Huh.
My palace only has one vacancy.
You're so right.
Alright, we'll save over time.
Suspicious video game generosity.
Is this gonna be my first boss?
I wonder.
We got money.
We gotta get the power.
Oh, that's some gunk on the floor.
Oh, I'm running.
Oh, what is this?
Open?
Goodbye.
Oh, I don't have anything for it.
Oh, well, there are no handprints around the part where the
doorknob should be.
Maybe a somewhat weird design, it seems.
Oh, handprints on the wall.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, sheesh.
Oh gosh!
Oh, get off of me!
Get off of me!
Oh, I'm crawling.
Can we get up, please?
Please.
Oh my gosh.
York.
Um.
Take them out one at a time?
Yeah.
And then you?
Bullseye.
Yeah, just take them out.
I'm gonna reload.
Wait, is this like a maze?
A maze, a maze.
Wait, I think I found my thing.
Oh, shoot.
Um, can I, uh, uh, can I attack it actually?
I had a feeling that was gonna happen.
Oh, get up, get up, get up, buddy!
Get up!
It's okay, we just save so if i die i don't care so much oh
please please turn around please turn around oh my god
flashbang goes crazy
is he dead then oh yeah he's dead shot yes see that done oh
yes no yes yes okay there's all the handprints here so maybe
we just uh do this yeah that's what i was trying to do and
that guy grabbed me like the grabby grabby is uh oh what the
heck is this They missed a tree!
They missed a tree in the tree!
Oh!
Wait, why is there a timer?
Wait, what's that mean?
Do I need to shoot- what?
Okay.
Easy puzzle.
A hand on the floor, shaped just like the ones on the door.
I got a doorknob!
Is this where I came in?
Where did I come in from?
Actually.
I should, I should heal, though.
Oh, though, though, I meant to do...
This one.
Yeah, that's good.
That's good.
Do I have to run all the way back?
Please say no.
Of course I do.
I don't remember how I got here.
Oh, shoot.
Turn around, buddy.
He doesn't even know where I'm shooting from.
And that epic battle has primed us.
why you're the boss boss okay um oh I'll grab that I think
we're in a different place now maybe
maybe if I go down this way
I'm not so keen on exploring in here it kind of scares me
it's too big you know we're running We're running, we're
running, we're running, we're running.
We'll just keep running.
I think it's down this hall.
And then we get to that room with the doors and all the
people and we ignore them and we press A.
We open the door.
I don't think they can get us because we're like in that
cussing, right?
The doorknob is shaped like a hand.
Classy for a lumber mill.
We'll need a little handshake to open the door.
Oh, get it off me.
Let's ignore everybody that's...
What is that?
Gum?
You got a peeled off fake fingernail.
Interesting.
Oh, we're gonna be looking for that then, I think.
I'm...
Yeah?
Wrong channel?
Hey.
Come here.
eyeballs what still don't know here the fake piece she's
running away oh she lost her fingernail they're kissing not
kissing I think I think it's the roots actually not quite
sure everything's so shaky
well um oh shoot i was hoping that oh my gosh uh turn around
please there we go oh my god no there's a third guy oh my
god please uh there we go okay okay okay i'm just gonna
switch to other gun.
I don't want to waste bullets on him.
Okay.
This time the door was being handsy.
Wait, so I can't go in here?
Oh, I can.
Like, what the hell?
Wait, why did it act like I couldn't, though?
Here I was.
I was like, oh no, now I don't know what to do.
I'm nervous.
Oh, what is that?
Observing something?
A vow for controlling the steam engine.
It's worn and could crack quite easily.
It might not be safe to touch it.
So true.
We're caring about your safety.
Uh.
Oh, what is this?
Oh.
Second scary room.
Okay.
All right.
I'm observing.
It's locked, but there's no keyhole.
Looks like it's the lock is on the other side.
All right Valve have like three real You heard it here first
folks What are the three mirrors?
Oh Oh, he's on the other side wait no, he's not.
Oh, he's behind me Oh, he opened the door for me
I hear him though
Could I shoot him
Why don't I get him in though?
Like pyramid head.
It doesn't lock on him.
Oh, God.
What the hell?
This guy is so extra.
I mean...
We could look around.
But also...
Speed.
It's just for no reason.
That's freaking out over there for no reason.
Oh, it's another one of these rooms.
I wonder if there's a...
Oh, we got money.
Okay.
Well, let's go, I guess.
Why are you going backwards?
Why are you backseating me, huh?
Because I missed that room!
Oh gosh.
I kind of want to see where he's sped off to.
I'm so nervous about what's in there.
Probably, I feel like I have a lot of supplies right now.
You know what I mean.
Oh no.
Wait, this area looks big.
Where's the power?
Oh, okay.
How am I...
I don't even know how I would get back to the elevator at
this point.
I know, this place is humongous, for real.
This is one of the more tedious dungeons.
I don't know if you're like meaning of this game or ever.
For every game ever.
Oh my god.
It's just never ending.
B!
I pressed B.
But, um...
Oh!
He doesn't ever...
Why does he do it?
What the?
Where am I even supposed to go?
Well, there's some cash in here.
Nice.
Trying not to get like, you know...
Is there something back there?
Because I see like a...
a goopy wall.
Goopy wall over here.
Dead end.
Dead end?
I don't... Oh, there's a turn here.
Of course.
Okay, a good thing I turned this way, not the other way,
because that was a dead end, too.
Thank you.
Who is he saying amazing to?
Is he, like, complimenting himself?
Like, man, damn, I'm good.
Can you break boxes and stuff with a pistol?
So you can, it just takes a lot longer.
Oh, look at that!
Nice.
Oh, whoops, prompt button.
This is Zach.
Zach is controlling us, maybe.
Thank you.
I do feel, I do like him complimenting me, though.
I'm not saying that I dislike it.
Oh.
What kind of hallway is that?
you know if you had to pick between pyramid head and this
sassy jawa what is that yeah here i'll show you how long it
takes it's so long it's a breakdown with the bullets from
star wars oh i thought so
Can I walk in here?
Okay, I'm guessing we're just going to want to run all the
way down there.
Run!
Is it locked?
Please don't be locked.
Okay, good.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
Okay.
Oh.
Save room.
Yes, I will save.
Thank you.
Why was he siding so hard?
Star Wars Watch Along win?
I know!
Hide!
Oh, I don't...
Okay, well at least we know that that is something we could
do.
I don't like knowing that at all.
I don't think I like knowing that.
Um, let's get...
Let's put our steel pipe.
Oh.
Oh, I think I just have to...
I guess I just have to use it until it's dead.
Wait, can I take our item out?
Uh...
Strength, low, durability, medium.
Everything's medium.
Durability, low, strength, medium, medium.
Golf club is high, though.
Oh, yeah, see, I have to just...
I just have to wait until...
Oh, shoot.
That's okay, though.
Take out the ammo?
I don't know if it'll let me...
It's okay, though.
I think we're fine.
How's my sleep?
Should we take a nap?
Oh, we're fine, though.
Um, a light sleep.
Literally napping on the job.
They're probably like, what's taking this guy?
What's taking this guy so long?
La la la.
I am napping.
Don't worry about me.
Smoke's hammer will moderate amount of our hunger.
Oh, nice.
Oh, yeah.
Hi.
Yeah, we left them in the rain even.
You're an asleepy.
This is a really long section, though.
Yep.
Okay, do we need to hide?
I'm scared.
Should I hide or should I answer the phone?
What's wrong with the TV?
White noise on the TV.
Who turned it on, I wonder?
Me, when I turned on the power, I think.
See you.
Hide!
No way, hiding uses stamina.
Does he?
Or...
Peek?
Oh!
I think now we hide.
Okay, I think.
Oh my gosh.
Hide quickly!
Uh, I'm trying.
There we go.
Oh, whoa!
We got the double- Sorry, I'm blocking a little bit of it.
We got the double camera.
Oh, we have his vision and everything!
Oh, shoot.
He won't know.
He won't.
I think we have to run after he goes over there, though,
right?
Probably.
I'm holding my breath.
He's sniffing me out?
Should I leave?
I don't know if I need to leave or if he leaves.
Oh, shoot.
Uh-oh.
Wait, I'm out of messed up.
Oh,
such a fast QTE!
It does say go out.
I don't know if I'm supposed to like run, you know, while
he's distracted, but I can't really tell.
Having the double screen is scary.
He stiffened me out!
I ended a 10-year friendship because my homeboy called you
his waifu.
Oh, you're the one giving me money.
I don't know what to tell you, brother.
I think you're worse.
Wait, what is that?
I didn't notice that before.
I think I am supposed to leave.
Unless he leaves first.
It's all so confusing.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, no!
My finger slipped!
Oh, my God.
No, please.
No.
Oh, my God.
My finger actually slipped.
No!
Investigation failure.
Wow.
But he wasn't even close to me.
Well, this is fine.
Uh, I'm gonna...
I still don't know if I need to like You know Like run as
he's At a different location Like you know observing
something else We could always try it It was a long cutscene
right?
That's why I couldn't tell If I needed to or not I don't
think I need to Resave I just did Like technically I saved
I'll do it again though.
I guess you can hide under here.
Oh, you can!
Okay.
Wait it out?
We'll wait it out then.
Sorry.
I've- I literally- I pressed the Z-R and my finger just went
right off of it.
Turn it on!
Okay, he gives up.
Okay, okay.
Cool, cool.
his POV, though.
I like that part.
Let's have a nap.
Patience is key.
Okay, I'm trusting you guys then.
Jawa was born.
Wouldn't normally backseat, but the section takes so long to
redo on any death.
No, no, no, I appreciate it.
It's okay.
I'm asking for help, so I don't really consider it
backseating, you know?
It's locked from the...
Oh, I got observation money.
We could take a peek through the window here.
Peek!
Hello?
Alright.
Hayah!
Uh, hide.
Hide.
Please.
Okay.
Oh my gosh, the door hit us!
The door slug all the way over to our locker.
That's crazy.
I like how the static on the TV is turned off.
Alright, my finger is ready.
Hold your breath!
I don't know why the flashing is giving me like arcade, you
know?
like when you're playing an arcade game and it tells you to
do something and it like starts flashing like that where's
he going
yeah time crisis yeah yeah it's like giving me that
what if it becomes a different button all of a sudden don't
say that don't say that
sniff sniffer sniffer sniffer and i hope I didn't have
garlic.
He sniffed me out with.
Aren't we supposed to be trying to catch this guy?
Like, he's our...
He's like, why don't we shoot him?
So glad he ignores our locker.
So good.
Yeah, he is pretty scary.
I think we enjoyed chasing after him, so...
That's why...
I mean, he is...
It feels a little paranormal.
Okay, surely he'll leave now.
Yahoo!
Let's save again.
My camera's being all buggy a little bit.
Zach, this is a waste of time.
Let's go.
What do you mean it's a waste of time?
What's a waste of time?
I'm running.
I don't remember how to get back to the elevator.
Oh, maybe I do.
No, I don't.
I don't.
Maybe I do.
I don't know.
Now to run all the way back.
Yes.
I took a turn.
Oh.
No, are you kidding me right now?
Ah!
Oh, oh.
Oh, okay.
Oh, climb, climb, climb!
Oh my god!
Oh, push!
Push, push, push, push, push.
Push, push, push, push.
Oh my gosh.
Why am I pushing?
Actually, why don't I just run?
Ah!
What happened?
What was the point?
of that.
What actually?
Please push.
Evade!
Oh,
you know what?
I kind of love this, though.
It's not telling me.
It's not making me remember how to get back at all.
This is kind of... Evade!
Okay, good, good.
Oh, evade was usually B, so I'm glad that I pressed the
right thing.
Running, running, running, running, running, running.
Oh, my arm is getting tired.
Please, please, open the door!
Oh, thank goodness he's waiting for us.
Okay.
Please.
This is so stupid.
Evade!
My iframes are insane.
He's opening.
He opens it so casually.
Oh my gosh, I'm actually...
Oh, my arm.
Oh!
I don't know even what I was evading.
I have no idea.
Wait, why did he lock himself How?
Why did he do that?
I'm not asking questions, but I'm also just kind of curious.
Oh, come on, buddy.
I don't have time for you.
That was the strangest Dead by Daylight solo survivor game
I've ever seen.
That was something.
It was so funny.
It was just so...
Out there!
I don't know.
Anyway.
Oh, I'm really... Actually, I would much prefer that than
having to remember how to get all the way back.
Why are we... Wait, why are we going back down?
Huh?
Wait, we went up?
We're not going even... Wait, we just came from down here,
no?
Huh?
Uh...
Are we back where we were before?
Maybe?
Ah!
Gosh, he scares me.
Oh my god.
They're gonna come rescue me, aren't they?
Wait!
Oh, I pressed X.
I'm gonna lose to the QTEs every time!
That's fine, this is fine.
X to doubt, yeah.
Look at him.
Oh, this is fine, this is fine.
I know, I did such a good job with running away.
Okay, Nintendo controller moment.
True, actually though!
I'm evading, I'm evading, I'm evading.
Okay, and it's gonna be something different.
Why?
It's not something different.
B!
It's so fast.
Oh!
I think I, like, instinctually, like, smashed all the
buttons up top.
It's Dark Souls.
What I didn't expect.
I've had my hand ready for like X and Y.
Not R!
Okay, okay.
I'm ready, I'm ready, I'm ready.
I'm ready, I'm ready.
Yeah, one of these is correct.
I'm evading.
Is it the same?
I hope.
Why?
Okay.
Then it was...
Uh...
V?
V.
Okay.
I just have to memorize it.
And then it's...
R.
What?
Ah!
I pressed B!
Oh!
Guys, I'm sorry.
It's so fast!
Holy cow!
Alright.
it.
Okay.
I know, good thing the inputs don't change, but I have to
memorize all of them now.
Oh my gosh.
It's okay, I think I got a plan.
You do?
Okay, let me know.
Okay.
Then it was Y.
Then it was B.
Then it was...
Or...
Hey!
Oh, I clicked.
What was it?
X?
Oh, I...
I did it.
I keep...
I keep pressing B.
I keep thinking of a...
I keep thinking of a PlayStation controller.
Okay, okay.
We're fine.
I keep missing the attack anyway.
It's always the X.
I know, because I press B.
We're fine.
we got this we got this we got this it's so funny because my
number of deaths is gonna go crazy high
wait you heard it though
wait what uh-oh controller did you guys hear
controller don't give up on me don't give up on me
Oh, all right.
All right.
Then it was Y.
Then it was B.
Then it was R.
Then it was A.
Oh, that's what happens when you press A.
Oh!
That's not attacking him.
Yeah, I kept missing that A every time.
Do do do do.
Oh, well, we just got rid of him, I guess.
Wait, what?
Torn piece of red raincoat.
Oh, nice.
We got our last thing.
I can profile!
That took me too long.
That took me way too long.
It's okay though.
We made it.
We're fine.
I'm profiling.
Start.
We're just playing around being sexy in the abandoned
lumberyard.
Hey.
Come here.
What?
I've never heard of this before.
Whoa.
What is that though?
What is the green thing?
She's like, uh-oh.
And then her fingernail.
Ooh.
I don't understand the kissy noise here.
Well done fleeing from the perpetrator, agent.
We'll catch him next time when we feel like it.
I literally am just like...
Yeah, I gotta go.
Like, I would rather shoot the elevator and send you up than
me...
Deal with you at the moment.
That's all the information we need, Zach.
Let's go back and show them what we found.
All right.
Do you mean the unsub?
Oh, yeah.
The unsub.
I can't get over the...
You know what?
I will give it this.
It is trying many different types of things.
Like the QTE fight.
And...
Oh, it's...
How long have I been in there?
Oh, I didn't.
nap, my bud.
The QT E-Fight and the running mechanic.
No, not that I know of.
But that raincoat is a little odd.
Odd?
In a town where it rains so much?
Well, the people here rarely go out in the rain.
I moved here during high school and i never really
understood why oh can you shed some light on this i heard
that people in pnw well there's an old story just don't care
they don't have umbrellas or anything it's a fairy tale to
me something about a killer in a raincoat who appears on
rainy nights a vicious killer in a bright red raincoat yeah
that was it oh um just a foolish piece of superstition a
rubbish story
still believe it but I guess it's a traditional place our
guy is a superstition still close up when it rains school's
out too but you live in the rainiest place ever you are all
rain no not many people and now the raincoat killer rain is
their element yeah they don't care right I heard that this
is true really oh by the way would you two kindly show me
your backs would you kindly our backs is this related to the
case would you kindly The person with the upside down piece
mark in that photo we found.
He's our killer.
And what makes you so sure about that?
Zach and I saw him kill off in the lumber mill.
Zach and I, who is Zach?
He killed her right in there.
He's trying a lot of different things I'm failing.
Please don't ask me about Zach.
That's a private matter.
Me and Zach saw it.
By the way, don't ask who Zach is.
of my concerns about you isn't that for the best you do want
to remove ourselves from the suspect we don't talk about
Zach it will make things a lot and I saw it this is insane
your methods are rude insulting and out of the question and
Emily is a female officer forcing her to show you her back
is harassment I don't care if you are FBI or not you are out
of line showing your back is harassment next you're gonna
ask us show your ankles too George it's okay Okay, let's
just show him and get it over with.
Emily, are you crazy?
Look, we flash our backs, and he'll start trusting us a
little more.
Yeah.
Right?
Agent York?
Of course, Emily.
Oh, oh, sorry.
It was a cut, Sansa.
Oh, the holy back of a woman.
It's so bright!
It's blinding!
Oh my god!
Are you satisfied now?
Yes.
My apologies.
Now you, George.
You could have lifted up your shirt by a shirt.
I can't refuse it now, can I?
But don't expect to get your way all the time.
The holy back of a man!
She may actually be more pale than you, probably!
Maybe she's dead also.
Oh my god!
George.
George, what happened to you?
What are these scars?
Just like you're Mr. Zack.
Something private.
I don't have to tell you about it.
Of course.
Just like Zack.
Who we don't talk about.
You can understand that, right Zack?
Right, Zack?
Yeah, you get it?
Anyway, this will make things a lot easier from now on.
I'm glad to say you're both pretty much off the hook.
Thank you for your cooperation.
What a weirdo.
Anyone is suspicious around here.
It's him.
He's the most suspicious.
No, I don't think so.
But he certainly is the most irritating.
Oh, I think she likes him.
You've studied the crime scene.
You know what we have to do next.
George, can we arrange to have the town folk gather in one
place?
All 600 of them?
Wait, what?
Very well.
That's still a lot of people.
We'll arrange to have as many as possible gather in the
community center tomorrow.
Thank you, George.
Why is it so goofy?
They're just like, yada, yada, what are we going to do?
to do about this guy?
I'm like...
I died so many times.
Don't look at it.
Wow, $6,000.
Yes, I do.
Welcome back, everyone.
Ah, Thomas.
Thomas!
Agent Morgan, it's past 2100.
Let's meet up again at the community center tomorrow.
I haven't been sleeping much since this all started, to be
honest.
I was just about to suggest the same thing.
I'll make arrangements for people to gather between 1,500
and 1,700.
I'll try and get as many people as I can to come, so don't
be late.
Okay, don't be late.
I'll be there.
The community center's on the south side.
I've marked it on your map.
Thanks, Thomas.
I love you, Thomas.
See you tomorrow.
You know when there's like male gays and female gays?
Thomas has female gays.
He's made for the ladies.
Right.
The lesbians.
Lesbians!
What about his back?
Man, life is beautiful.
Isn't that right, Zach?
I wonder if there's any cards around here.
Oh!
There is, there is!
Oh, it's over there.
What does this mean?
This doesn't mean to go back inside, does it?
Oh!
No, I don't think there are any useful clues left here, but
maybe I should give it a try just for the thrill of it.
No, I am done with this.
I am done with...
Get me out of here.
That's so funny.
The thrill.
The thrill of it.
Wait, how do I get out of there?
I think the opening is right there.
Do you see the moon?
It's humongous!
Just for the thrill.
What a thrill.
Can I bust this open?
Holy cow!
I am kind of insane.
I might be the most strong man ever.
There's Pokemon in here.
I just don't understand.
Like, I think the exploration is great and dandy and fun,
but I don't understand why the maps are so huge for no
reason.
The maps are actually gigantic.
Like, look at there's nothing here!
It's an empty field!
Like, this part does not need to be so large!
Oh, there's nothing here!
Okay.
I don't know how to get in there.
York is going crazy.
He's yorking out.
We have to stop him.
It's the yard yard.
It's the yard where they store the yard.
Sorry, I go take you so much.
We're going to see what we're going to take you.
Oh, my heart is going crazy.
I see the card.
It's right there.
Maybe that's why I need to go back through.
Hmm.
Yeah, probably that reason, right?
Is the moon right?
Wait, the moon does rise.
That's crazy.
Did you watch it?
It just went...
Oh, there it goes!
There it goes!
It's the most graceful moon rise you ever done so.
It's turning in from the local Takaria after...
Poll work.
Oh, there's a squirrel!
Oh my god!
Happy Cinco de Mayo!
Nicholas, happy Cinco de Mayo!
I got tacos.
Little squirrel went in a row.
So where am I?
Oh, tomorrow we are meeting with people.
That's right.
We are in the town hall.
For now, we're chill.
We're chilling.
Yeah, we're free to explore.
This is so exciting.
I wonder if I can, like, ram this over.
No.
It looks like it really is telling us to, like, go back and,
like, do the whole thing again to find the car.
Find the way to get to the car, maybe.
Milk barn?
How do I get out of here?
Right, Zach?
Jennifer Gray.
She's in one of my most favorite movies.
Ferris Bueller's Day Off.
Oh, Ferris Bueller.
1986, directed by John Hughes.
That one was so 80s.
Zach, you're not the most cheerful guy I know.
But you really do like those cheerful movies.
We used to love those teenage movies back then, didn't we?
Breakfast Club, Pretty and Pink, St. Elmo's Fire, at fast
times at Ridgemont High.
Uh-huh.
That last moment was in 1982 directed by Amy Hecker.
I wonder if Zach ever gets tired of him talking to him.
Zach doesn't ever talk back.
Baby Cates, not to mention Nicholas Cage and Forrest
Whitaker were in it too.
And the original book and the script were in Bucky Memory
Crow.
We're not going to do it.
We're not going to do the thing.
Do you remember, Zach?
When that movie ended, the last words the end was from an
arcade game.
That's right.
It was from Missile Command.
Zach is trying to destroy the shock alarm.
York's the streamer and Zach is chat.
Yeah, Zach.
What do you want to see, Zach?
What do you want to see?
Actually, there are some things I want to see.
There's the new Backrooms movie coming out at the end of
this month.
I'm excited about that one.
I heard okay things about that Holcomb movie.
It seems kind of...
It's like Irish folklore, I think.
Star Wars!
Okay, fine.
I will watch Star Wars.
Wait.
Am I supposed to go that way?
Where?
Am I going the wrong way?
Was there like another exit?
Or...
A few horror movies you're curious about?
Yeah.
Oh, I'm going the right way.
Okay.
I'm trusting you.
Because this is the way I came in, right?
Digital Circus!
I want...
I'll be honest.
I'm not going to go see it in the movies.
But...
I'll wait the two weeks until it's...
Until it's, you know.
Holy cow.
Turn, oh, these dang LED lights.
They need to be illegal.
Oh,
we're going the right way.
Yeah, I won't go because I, you know, I'm not someone.
I, I've never been this way.
I'm like someone who enjoys things, but I feel like I never
participate in like the fandom of it all.
enjoy the medium as it is i think that's why like like i'll
get into something but i just like you know i just never
talk to other people about it i just like it so
um i don't i don't even really have anyone to go see it with
but also i'm afraid of the digital circus fandom
But yeah, usually, yeah, I just kind of keep them myself
with, like, things that I like and...
Things that...
Which is fine, but it does get, like, a little, I guess,
because it's, like, fun having camaraderie with, you know,
things that you're into.
And that's not to say that I have, like, nobody that, like,
that are into things that I'm into.
Like, you know, I have friends that are into idols and
things like that, so...
Oh!
What?
What just happened?
Excuse me.
Oh.
Is it a one?
What am I stuck on?
Um, is this there an invisible wall?
What?
I think there's an invisible wall.
Nope.
Wait.
Okay, Zach.
I've been thinking about what movie I'd like to watch.
Hold on.
I need to see.
We'll finish our chat later.
Let's take a walk around here.
I need to see.
Zach, is there something here that you want to check out?
Yes.
We need to be at the community center by 1500 today.
Just think of talking in front of all those people.
It's not... What do you mean today?
I think you mean tomorrow, no?
It's going to get fun.
Because it's way past the 1500.
Do it.
What's to your license plate say?
FBI!
Give me your car!
Okay.
I tried murder.
There was an attempt.
They're so unbothered.
That might...
be the bestest, the bestest car ever made ever.
Wait, what's wrong with my...
Do you see my windshield?
Wait a second.
Does my...
Why did we...
Wait, did we just turn on the engine?
My car's not busted, is it?
No, it's fine.
Huh, weird.
But Your Honor, Zach told me to.
Yeah, it has a crack in it.
Is this the community center or is this home?
I don't know where I'm driving to.
Just a weird texture.
Where are we going?
Oh.
Oh yeah, he said his movie that he wanted to.
Yes.
I've been thinking about what movie I'd like to watch.
Yes, I want to know.
And finally I've made a decision.
What is it?
It's always hard to narrow it down just to one movie.
But I've put a lot of thought into this.
Uh-huh.
And I'm sure you'll agree with me.
What?
1975.
Directed by Stephen Spielberg himself.
Yes.
A grandfather of panic movies.
Set in a small town in Massachusetts.
E.T.
That movie made me stay away from the beach for years.
Jaws!
I was afraid that a hand might come floating up.
Jaws.
You know what I'm talking about, right?
Yep.
It's Jaws.
That is a huge tree!
I'd never been that scared by a movie before but the best
thing about it is that it isn't just another panic movie the
mayor who won't close the beach even when there are so many
victims and chief Brody putting the citizens lives above all
else the film gave a lot of time to the dispute and friction
between them certainly had a lot of messages for a two-hour
film that's probably another reason why it was such a
record-brick Hmm?
Hmm?
Zach will finish our chat later.
Let's take a walk around here.
Yeah.
Wait, how did I park all the way over here?
How?
Oh, whoops, that's not what I meant to do.
I'm too greedy.
I'm too like greedy for...
Let's save over here.
I see a phone.
I want to explore, but it's like so...
It's so huge.
I didn't know how to get back home.
home.
Oh, we can also get food and stuff.
Let's buy.
Buy, buy, boy, boy.
A lollipop or some crackers.
I forgot the crackers are $35.
Are you sure?
Even the game is questioning it.
Are you sure you want to buy the $35 crackers?
There's a few shops in town still open.
Okay.
Yeah, we were going to go to... Can I... Let's, uh, is there
anything in here?
Hide!
From what?
Oh, that's terrifying.
Yeah, let's go to the bar.
Okay, I'll save.
This is dead by daylight.
Maybe Zach can't hear us if we're like, you know...
This tree is crazy.
New car.
Okay, I wish there was a way to, like, mark something on the
map where you want to go, you know?
Let's see.
Map.
Oh, but town is, like, right here.
Uh.
Sheriff's department.
Oh, so we're really close, actually.
Uh.
A is...
What's this?
I'm trying to...
Uh...
Doesn't seem like anything.
This is Anna's house.
Brian's house.
Galaxy of Terror.
Where's the milk bar?
A-N-G diner.
We can go there.
Oh my gosh, I get it.
Is this where we are?
Yeah.
And we drive out and we just go straight.
Okay.
Why do the streets change names at every intersection?
Holy cow, you're right!
Oh my gosh!
Wait!
So you have Frost Street, stop.
Cap Street, stop.
Cherry Street, stop.
Hail Street, stop.
What is this?
Where is the- Where is the- oh, here we go.
Electric substation.
Fishing.
This is a heaven and hell gas station.
Junkyard?
George's home?
Milk barn!
Oh, it's kind of far.
Um, let's see.
What's the easiest way to get there?
Maybe...
Okay, we head out of here.
No, not this way.
Okay, we're gonna go back to town.
And when we get to Hale Street, or Donovan Street, either
one, left and we just go down down down down to the milk bar
will you guys help me out oh i didn't mean to get out dang
it no please
down down down by the river all right all right then my
passenger princesses welcomes aboard The Minto Explorer
is...
I will lead you to the safety and to your destination very
safely and also very comfortably.
Are you cold princess, please feel free to adjust the air
conditioning as you please fit feel and fit.
Picking up from where we left on.
Okay, sir.
Oh, I've been thinking about what movie I'd like to watch
next.
Oh, we had to have this whole conversation again?
it's always hard to narrow it down just gonna go on his
whole but i've put a lot of thought into this okay and i'm
sure you'll agree with me 1975 directed by stephen
speidelberg himself a grandfather of panic okay we're on
humped dumpy lane in a small town in massachusetts that
movie made me stay away from the beach for years i was
always afraid that a hand might come okay here it is here uh
you know what i'm talking about
The underwater camera work accompanied by that John Williams
music.
I've never been that scared by a movie before.
But the best thing about it is that it isn't just another
thing.
Here's a little driving tip.
If someone's too slow, you can always pass them on the
sidewalk.
Ah!
Turn off your high beams!
You son of a bitch!
I don't know how to do the dispute and friction between
them.
I certainly had a lot of messages for a two-hour film.
Left now!
Sorry, no!
Only another reason why it was such a record-breaking hit.
Ah!
One of the reasons in life is that I didn't see it at the
movie theater.
I guess I was still just a child back then.
But still, I wanted to taste that terror in real time.
Taste the terror.
That sounds like a slogan.
Jaws also appears in another movie that was produced by
Spielberg.
The second Back to the Future.
Really?
It was directed by Robert Zemeckis.
Okay, hold on, everybody in the world.
That's also a masterpiece.
I don't know where I am going.
I'll discuss that another time.
I need to look at the...
I need to look at my map.
Sorry, everybody.
This is, oh, you know, those people that, like, wait.
Um, am I going the right way?
Wait.
It's right here?
Here.
Okay, just a little bit more.
You know those people that are like, oh no, I...
I got...
I have to actually get off on this road.
Okay.
that actually oh my gosh that happened to me today i was
driving and there was a person that was just stopped in the
middle of the road with their blinker on trying to get into
the left lane but the left lane was like completely full of
people and it was also a red light and so like by my light
was green and they were just stopped for no re not for no
reason but they just Is that the milk bar?
Excuse me, everybody.
Oh, that's gas station.
Milk bar's a little...
I hate that.
Like, uh...
Like, just take the L and go and turn.
You turn at the next thing.
Like, what are you doing?
You're just inconveniencing everybody else.
A bad driver never misses their turn.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
Why is there a gun here?
Hold on, I'm checking the map again.
What I'm trying to say is I'm being that person right now a
little bit.
What is this place?
Panda bear.
I'm curious.
There, and I will go check.
Oh, it's close.
Ah, man.
Yeah, York is being that person.
Oh, it's so true.
Not me.
I'm a good driver.
The milk bar.
Tochak!
Yeah, it's late.
It's only 10.
That's exactly...
Wait, that's exactly what time it is for me, right?
No.
Just think of talking in front of all those people.
What time did you close?
It's going to get fun.
What?
It's lost.
We're missing pizza pizza!
You're literally called a milk bar.
You should be open until at least 1 a.m.
What else is open?
We could go to the twisted, uh, what was it?
Um, pizza pizza.
What was the other one?
The terror or something, something or other?
Emily's house.
I think it was back up here, though.
Here?
Galaxy of Terror.
Let's go back there.
Surely that place is open.
Otherwise, we're going to have to find a place to sleep.
Oh, everybody, just giving you a heads up, that was a red
light.
You're supposed to stop.
But York is in a hurry.
Official police business.
Better to just sleep.
Oh, we're exploring now.
We finally have a chance.
We'll explore just a little bit and then I'll sleep.
Kanse Dorifto.
Huh?
Nothing.
Just my imagination.
Oh, now you're imagining things.
Very interesting.
York is the law.
Wait, there's a card in here.
Let's grab it.
Stop!
Nice.
Alright.
Let's get this card.
Of what?
What could it be?
My game feels like it's lagging a lot.
I wonder why.
Raging bull.
Oh!
Jack the Someone we haven't I think someone we haven't met
yet
Where's my car?
Wait, where's my car?
Wait, where did I put...
Oh, there's a right there.
Is my switch getting hot?
I don't know.
It's plugged up.
Wait, is this my car?
Wait, where's my car?
Oh!
Oh, you scared me.
My Switch could be overheating.
It could be overheating.
I heard that this game is difficult to play on Switch 2
because the game is like the frame rate works too properly.
It hasn't crashed on Switch.
Oops.
Ugh.
Oh, this is...
Such riveting conversation.
Thank you, York.
Yeah, I heard this game is the worst on PC.
So, that's why we're on the Switch, baby.
Am I going the right way?
We're checking.
Galaxy of Terror.
Okay.
We turn at...
Uh, how...
Harrison Strait.
Right.
Hey, buddy.
Calm down.
Hold on.
Uh, I think this is it.
What?
You're also closed!
There's no way!
Everything is closed!
Yeah, my blinker was on.
They should have given me the right of way.
Where is that?
Swery 65.
I don't know where that is.
Ah, I had to pay a dollar to use the phone.
What is it?
What am I peeking into?
Is this a changing room?
Is this a bathroom?
Oh,
my eyes are darting everywhere.
Um, your head is fully inside the room.
Can you imagine I'm like, I look like a skippity toilet.
Peaking at the wrong time.
We gotta come back in the day, baby.
It's empty.
It's like such a long...
It's such a long loading screen.
I can peek in...
What is up here?
Record player.
Oh, is this a card?
Oh, nice.
I don't even know there was one here.
See, it wasn't all for nothing.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, good, good, good.
Is it the same room?
Whoa.
Why are we just allowed to peek in here?
What is this?
Well...
Uh...
We shall...
Yeah, very cabaret-like, right?
for being a peepin' tom.
I don't know where Swery 65 is.
Yeah, I'm the FBI.
I'm able to look in every window ever.
Sheriff's, bank, diner.
A diner might be open.
And that's George's house.
It's up the road.
Oh.
A farm.
We could sleep at the barn.
Freckles.
Okay, how far up the road?
Okay, that's the end of the road.
Uh, this thing guy goes to the hospital?
Yeah.
Uh, past Milk Barn?
Okay, that's down the road.
That is down.
Wait, it's all the...
Oh, I don't want to go past Milk Barn.
Oh, what's...
Oh, so we can sleep at the graveyard.
Wait, can we go sleep at the graveyard?
Guys, that sounds really exciting.
There's more bones.
And...
More bones.
And a tree of...
Oh, this is the tree.
The graveyard is the best place to sleep because it has
infinite tomatoes.
What is this place?
The farm.
We could sleep in the middle of the farm.
This is incredible.
What?
There's literally nothing here.
We could just sleep there.
Uh-huh.
What's this?
Usha!
Usha's house!
I lost the graveyard.
What's this?
White Spruce Farm?
Gas station.
Okay, hold on.
It was right down here, no?
Yes, yes, yes.
All right.
Maybe we will go back to the milk barn that...
Wait.
This is the milk barn.
Ah, Swery 65!
It really is down there.
Wait, there was one other thing I wanted to look at on the
map, sorry.
Uh, oops.
Oh my goodness, shut up.
Oh, I think I was thinking of the diner.
You think the diner is open?
No.
Okay, it's not.
Oh, wait, no, that was my mission.
Just kidding.
Uh, it's fine.
Let's grab my car and let's...
We're going all the way.
We're going to go to sleep at the graveyard, everybody.
Did you guys hear that?
What the heck was that noise?
Something's going on in the general mode.
What?
I'm hearing noise.
am hearing noises is there a bear in there for real oh it's
a dog do you see his ears when he runs wait walk around dog
i want to see your ears they like they like bend backwards
Oh my goodness.
He's got quite, he's sniffing and snuffing all over the
place there.
Alright, sorry.
I know we're driving all around.
I mean, it's fine.
We're exploring a little bit.
We can go grab my car.
And head back to the milk bar, but also just a little bit
down.
We'll go check out the Swery.
Swery.
I just want to go inside a place, you know?
I think I'm going the right way.
Maybe I'm not.
No.
Okay, I have to go this way instead.
Maybe?
I remember Harrison.
No, I'm lost.
Hmm?
No, nothing.
Just my imagination.
We're out of movie talk!
I'm lost.
Sorry, everybody.
Wait, which way do I go?
This way?
Okay.
It's down this way, right?
No?
Wood path?
No.
Oh my gosh, I'm so lost.
I wish I could zoom out.
the map a little bit more where the heck is a farm maybe I
go this way great deer yard hotel big fish wait what yeah
this is the most zoomed out it can be this is zoomed in why
you needed that zoomed in for any reason makes I'm actually
lost wait what the heck oh Wait, uh, and this is the...
Swearie.
Okay, hold on.
Let's follow this big road.
Following the big road, following the big road.
Okay.
I think I know.
We make a left, and then we'll make the next...
Okay, okay, I got it.
I got it.
Left.
Oh, oops.
Sorry, my bad.
And not here, but we go down here.
and then we'll take a right, I think, at this road right
here.
Where, uh, this road?
I think, and then we just drive down it.
All right, we are exploring, everybody.
Okay, I think we just head down this way.
Nice.
At that point, you might as well use an actual map.
It's, like, so tough to tell.
Get out of the way, Grandpa.
Get off the road.
Why are their lights so blinding, though?
We're going to go to Swery.
65, and then we'll sleep at the cemetery.
Good plan, everybody.
I can also Oh my headlights aren't even on Oh my gosh nobody
knew that I was Driving And they don't do much
Dangerous Driver I'm driving without my Headlights on at
night Out of the I'm blinding them look at them They're
trying to get out of the way because they're blinded Yeah Oh
so am I I'd better get something to eat soon, Zach.
Oh, good thing we're going then.
It's a good thing we're going to a place to get food then.
Yield, civilian.
And then luckily, close to here is the cemetery where we
will be napping, even though we apparently...
I guess we have a hotel room, but I'm not quite sure where
that is.
You're gonna kill somebody!
We're here?
Slary 65.
Oh, it's open!
Oh, we can peek.
We can peek.
We can be a little weirdo.
I don't know.
I've never darted before.
Is this place packed?
Oh!
We have a different soundtrack.
That's huge.
Hey, don't turn around, buddy.
Someone's watching you.
I don't know.
It feels like somebody's watching me.
Chocolate chip cookie.
Oh, I want a chocolate chip cookie.
Sounds good.
Okay.
I'm gonna bust- I'm gonna open both doors like a cowboy.
Oh, never mind.
I'm being quite polite.
You just bought some!
I bought cookies too.
But not chocolate chip.
Wow, this place is packed.
Hello.
Everyone's watching the sports program.
Understandably, as entertainment must be scarce up here.
No new songs.
oh never mind we might have gotten the best song in the
soundtrack oh
oh it just loops that over and over again it's kind of
terrible hey you're a suspect let's hear what this person
has to say hello Anna where are you going don't leave me
Sally Graham Anna's mother A graham.
I got cookies, the raspberry.
Do you know where Anna is?
Anna.
My dear Anna.
Maybe we should turn off the music.
Zach, let's do this later.
I don't think we'll get anything out of her like this.
We hear sweary's a chain.
This one is 65, 66 is the next town over.
Then there's one more down the street.
I wonder what number that would be.
Thanks for the cookie!
Okay, this song is terrible.
You can hear it where it loops because it's not like a...
It's not a perfect loop.
Howdy.
Suspect.
I'm FBI special agent, Francis York Morton.
Call me York.
But why does that bring the FBI here?
Quint Dunn.
I have an interest in murder cases involving young women.
Well, you know, man, this might just be another case.
to you but it means the death of a friend to me and i want
you taking this lightly like it's just another case i never
take anything of this nature lightly i assure you why would
you think of taking it lightly when the fbi is yeah because
the fbi can't shine their own boots right good point you
can't always count on the police now can you but that
doesn't mean you're going to capture the perpetrator
yourself quaint how do you know my name i memorize the name
of every
your significant other you mean Becky what about Becky don't
underestimate the FBI we know and see everything as Zach is
whispering everything I'm like here if I was a little harsh
I want to help I do okay okay Zach I'll tell you how I knew
his name he's got a small Q on his hat that was the only
name beginning with Q that I could think of he was even kind
enough to tell us his girlfriend's name I can read him like
a book Zach
That was the only name I could think of that starts with a
cute one.
I'm FBI Special Agent Francis York Morgan.
Oh my god, call me York.
That's what everyone calls me.
York sounds like a last name.
Okay, Richard Dunn.
York is so...
I'm Richard Dunn.
I own one of the bars here.
It's called Swery 65.
How'd you like the town?
Oh, it's great.
This sounds like... He does not sound like a voice actor.
just doesn't fit with a small town like ours sounds like
they just pulled a guy off the street it was like you're
voicing richards don't care about size big town small town
just isn't a factor I guess you're right so how did you know
Anna I've known her since she was a child she was the same
age as my son she always stood out being pretty and all just
like her mother Sally you seem to know a lot how long have
you been in love with her hey hey don't go there that scar
yours tells me you got your hands full too right what let's
not dive into personal matters it'll be better for you and
me you're right richard collecting gossip won't help with
the matter at hand
hello wait is there anything down here
probably shouldn't try to get in there oh what's in here
we're investigating fbi open up wait what is in here
actually Where did we go?
Legend worm!
Oh!
Oh.
Whoopsie-poopsie.
What's this?
Can I look in their window?
No way.
I'm just gonna do a little bit of a peek inside your trailer
home.
Thanks for making overtime variables.
MK, good luck with overtime, good luck with work!
There's something, there's money that I can take from your
home.
This is huge in here.
Let's peek, Zach.
Zach, it's not me, it's Zach.
Zach is telling me to look inside people's homes and to raid
women's dressers.
Hot dog!
Wait, with the tomato, it looks amazing.
I swear, officer, it wasn't me.
You know how Zach can be.
He's so pushy.
All right, let's go to sleep.
Oh, wait.
I want to play darts real quick.
I do want to try the darts.
I've come to like a slice of tomato in my dog.
Don't ask me about Zach.
It's private.
Number third, play darts.
If you get a good score, I will give you a present.
One play is $50.
Inflation to be hit in this small town real hard.
You want to play darts here?
You need a dart gun.
You can buy one at my bar.
Oh, okay.
I'd like to buy...
Hey!
What is on the TV?
Do you see that up there?
What is happening?
What is going on?
What would you recommend?
A tequila sunrise?
McJaggers' love affair with one of these beauties is well
documented.
Okay, so you're a romantic one.
All men are romantic, you know.
Even you, I'm sure.
Ask yourself seriously.
By the way, did you see Quint's menu?
As many as a little different from mine.
Just adds a little personality to the place, right?
You pick whichever you want to serve.
What about Dart Gun?
I'll buy.
The Dart Gun?
Handcrafted by Richard?
$500 and 50 cents.
What a steal.
No,
I...
Jambalaya!
Yummy!
Wait, did we get a...
You ate a lot.
Oh, I was hungry.
Spicy tacos!
Oh, no.
There was the, uh, wait.
There was the toolbox over here.
But it's okay.
I'm sure we'll have to come back anyway.
What's this though?
Wait, what's this?
Oh, cigarette.
And what are you?
A shovel.
I'll take...
I'll take that.
Nice.
Why, yeah, why are the cigarettes heavy?
What did they do?
Heavy.
Do cigarettes have a classification like that?
Sort of like how...
Uh...
I don't know.
They weigh a lot.
You skip time, we can woe-ho.
Woe-ho!
Woe-woe-woe!
Okay, let's go sleep at the graveyard.
Woe-ho!
What the heck?
that expresses rain by turning around we are getting some
okay it's time to go to sleep i think we're getting some
bizarre choices here in the loading screen how do i get to
the the darts challenge is definitely worth doing by the way
okay we'll do it next time for sure
i just feel like i've spent quite a bit of time oh here we
go we go down Nightbird Way.
I think?
Wait, is this the graveyard?
No.
Just kidding.
Where's the graveyard?
What is this?
Oh, the farm?
I didn't think it was that far.
No, no, no, no.
Muse's Gallery.
It was far.
I know the map rotates.
It drives me insane, actually.
Is this it?
Drunkyard.
Okay, I give up.
It's actually...
The map moving is nonsensical.
Oh, wait.
I found it!
Okay, it's not that far.
Wait.
It's not that far.
We go towards the milk barn and we go down the road and we
make it to it.
Okay.
We turn down Tree Street to...
Let's go back.
Oh my gosh.
Alright.
Now which way?
I think it's this way.
Is back towards the milk barn.
Yeah.
And then we turn on tree street.
Did I pass it?
No, no.
Here, here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Tree street.
Okay.
Hmm.
Just my imagination.
I actually prefer maps rotate rather than the player icon.
You don't find it too difficult to...
This map is insane.
You don't find it too difficult to keep track though?
I don't know.
I would rather it like say up is north and and down to
south, you know.
Make it nice and easy for my little brain.
Am I going the right way still?
I sure hope so.
Shortcut.
I think I'm still going the right way.
We just need to sleep at this point.
Maybe here?
This looks like a cemetery maybe.
Yeah!
I wonder where we'll be sleeping at.
Where are we gonna be sleeping at?
Big map, big map, rotating is bonkers.
Small map, sure.
It's true, right?
When I'm driving...
Is there something here that you want to check out?
We need to be at the community center by 1500 today.
When I'm driving...
Just think of talking in front of all those people.
What do you think, Zach?
I think it's fine.
But if I'm checking where I need to go...
Shh.
This grave has been dug up.
Why would anyone do such a thing?
Oh, okay.
I thought that was our bed.
kidding.
Oh, here it is!
How lovely!
How nice!
Oh, I hear a dog.
There's always a dog around the bones.
Hey, York.
I think there's a spooky maid in the graveyard.
All right, let's go to sleep let's sleep for a deep sleep
nine hours we're gonna be nice and rested hmm
me too where are those tomatoes yeah where's the tomatoes
everyone talked about them tomatoes how do I get in here let
me in
Buy the bun?
Oh, this part.
I thought this was, uh...
Oh!
I thought this was, um...
What's it called?
The phone.
Nice!
Oh.
Another one!
Are you gonna play the new Lego Batman game?
I don't know, maybe.
Oh!
Nice!
Oh, you can't keep...
No!
Wait, am I hungry?
Wait, uh...
Wait, oh, here we go.
A small amount.
Okay, nice.
We'll get some more now.
Eat it.
I eat it.
Are you tomatoes like apples?
I do.
I don't know about a green tomato.
Green tomatoes equals tummy hort.
York guys, York is just built different, okay?
Please understand.
Maybe we can nap for like another two hours.
Or something.
Six?
Oh, three hours.
Wait, stinky?
I got taxed for being smelly.
Is that what it just said?
Wait, there's something in here.
Oh, money.
Stinky tax!
Breakfast?
It says breakfast.
Is that from...
Is that at my hotel?
How do I get to my hotel?
But also breakfast until 1 p.m.
is very...
generous i'd say i don't know how to get to i don't even
know where i am where yeah they're fly ew they're flies like
in my car
you go left and follow the road all the way down they down
right to the hotel really okay okay nothing no new
conversation i thought it was the next day we would finally
get a new conversation all right we're gonna follow the this
road all the way down and hope it gets to the hotel.
It's almost 11 a.m.
We have to hope that we can get there before breakfast.
Boom, boom, boom, bing.
I need to feel my switch, though.
I'm worried.
I'm worried that it's overheating.
Wee, wee, wee, wee.
And I should probably shower and change my clothes.
Oh, God, that was a big fly.
We're getting brunch now.
We're getting brunch.
Oh, we're at the milk bar.
Hold on.
It is down here, right?
If I keep going, wait.
No, if I keep going, This is someone's house.
Uh-oh.
It splits.
This is Usha's house.
This one!
Polly!
Okay.
So we make a ride at the end of the street.
Meow, meow, meow.
I wonder how much longer I can go though.
See?
Will we make it in time for breakfast?
Nobody...
Oh, there's like...
Oh, maybe people's mailboxes.
This game has everything!
You can interact with anything!
It's kind of insane!
It's like actually crazy.
Also, these clouds are like going at 2 frames per second.
Yeah!
Use your blinker next time, buddy!
I can't believe we got this game before GTA 6.
Crazy.
Imagine going back to the nice hotel lady.
And being like, I slept in a graveyard.
Wait, is that why I got stinky, you think?
Because I slept in the graveyard?
Outside?
This is GTA 2.5.
No, you just get smelly.
after a while.
Oh, okay.
It's because I need to change my clothes, right?
That's all I have to do.
Well, good.
We're technically getting closer to the place.
So once we eat, then we can just drive.
So there's actually no fast travel in this game?
Was it here?
No, that's just a place to sleep.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, the people here drive crazy like.
I was passing.
There is, but you kinda, you do a kinda out of the way side
quest to get it.
Oh, you have to unlock fast travel.
What the hell to unlock?
Oh my gosh.
Requires a god.
Are we almost there?
Oh my gosh, everywhere takes actually like 10 hours to drive
to.
I think we're almost there.
We'll boost it.
Step on it!
Oh, wait, I think here?
I think this is it.
I think this is our hotel.
Quite possibly the largest map in video game history.
Skyrim Hool.
Everybody hop on Hop on deadly premonition
So much to do So much to see So what's wrong with taking
Every single road that you can see And then every building
is just Huge for literally no reason The fact that this
hotel has actually maybe a hundred rooms It's so crazy.
Hello, Polly.
Oh, hi.
What can I do for you, Mr. Morgan?
Buy.
What am I buying?
She's got bullets?
Coffee, stabilizer, flare, cigarette.
Oh, smoking them will make you forget the time is going by.
The $114!
Miss Polly, you are...
I think...
Where's my room, now that I think about it?
Am I upstairs?
Oh, no.
Wait.
This is a museum.
This whole town is out to scam anybody and everybody.
Oh, is this my room?
Oh, thank goodness!
Alright, stinky.
Let's shave and change our clothes.
I was buzzing around me.
We're gonna get a, we're gonna get the cutscene with Oslaw.
You stink.
Everything is just kind of actually needlessly huge.
They were like, we're giving you the feeling of a real of a
real rural rural village experience.
Sleeping in my own bed.
Who needs it?
We'll do our agent suit.
Oh, we gotta look good for our presentation.
Okay, this one.
Cleaning.
$10!
It'll take 24 hours for it to get cleaned.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, baby.
Alright, let's save.
That's how you get unstinky.
You don't even shower.
This game has everything and it's also so backwards.
What do you mean that I just only change clothes to remove
my stink?
I don't shower?
Oh, shoot.
Oh, I think it's this way.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right.
Convention logic.
No, we did shave.
yeah i don't think that even like i don't think we like wash
our face or anything aren't you not supposed to shave dry
like you should wet your face no or shaving cream anything
oh i have so many messages oh hold on
uh i'll check after stream
Okay.
Where's my car?
Dry is crazy, right?
You can shave dry.
You can!
That doesn't hurt.
You guys, like, moisturize your faces and stuff, right?
Use warm water to soften things and shave.
Then use after shave.
to close everything up.
You got the...
You got the strat?
Okay.
Did you eat the can of pickles yet?
I absolutely did.
We still have...
Oh wait, no, I forgot to eat breakfast!
My breakfast!
Moisture, what?
Oh, don't say that to me!
What do you mean to me?
Sadly, you don't moisturize.
We need the skincare stream, please.
I feel like maybe people get...
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
They get...
Like, overwhelmed by skincare.
It's actually so easy.
All you need to do is wash your face.
You can use a toner if you want.
And moisturize.
Bada bang, bada boom, baby.
Easy.
is this it it was here right i've been wearing a beard for
like 15 years but when i did shave i did it dry and it was
like doable but it irritated my face oh i see oh here we go
coffee oh no wait miss polly what wait what's my coffee say
wait what does my coffee say do not act without thinking
first lucky number three so my lucky number is three today
the first case I worked after joining the FBI had three
victims
oh oh here's where's the food can I eat wait it says though
that this is breakfast time oh my god we got bamboozled Oh,
at the police station.
You may only observe the food.
The meal is at the police station.
Okay.
What?
Home.
I feel like we haven't done anything for like the past hour.
Oh, my God.
I'm playing the game and we haven't done literally anything
for the past hour.
Oh, Thomas is making lunch.
I love that guy.
What was that?
I'm getting contacted by aliens, I think.
Welcome to deadly...
Wait, what is that thing, though, on my map?
It looks like a little dessert.
Where is the police station?
Oh, my God.
I'm getting tired, to be honest.
You're getting tired, Cadence.
You're getting tired.
I'm a tire.
How do you think I feel?
How do you think I feel driving back and forth, doing all of
this?
I'm getting tired.
How do you think I feel?
Oh, here's our food.
Right, right, right.
Okay, we just drive.
First left.
I'm a tire.
All right, Mario sound and ash.
You just woke up, Minto.
Oh, I'm breaking my car.
We gotta get around this guy.
He's a danger on the road.
Oops.
Whew.
Nearly hit that pole.
I'm a tire.
See, if you drive on the left side of the road, when
everyone else is driving on the right side, you can pass
them.
Another little life hack.
Brought to you by me.
Oh, gosh, watch out.
Had my blinker on.
Oh, okay, it's here.
And ride again.
I'm always right.
Never left.
Toe-chack!
Wait, we can also peek in here.
Why am I being a little creepazoid?
Why am I...
Why am I looking through everybody's windows all of a
sudden?
I mean, I don't hate it.
I got rear-ended on the way to work this morning on the
highway.
You didn't have it?
No, you didn't!
You're lying, right?
Official Department of Minky Vehicles.
I'm learning so much about driving today.
Thank you, Minto.
Of course.
Okay, who's...
Who's in here?
Anybody?
What's the point of peeking if nobody is changing?
York Morgan, FBI, Freaky Boy Institute.
Correction, last hour and a half.
absolutely nothing because he went up to go down again
you're so right Nicholas how could I forget oh you're so
right all right we're gonna we're gonna eat and then we're
gonna smoke and forget the time and then we're gonna go do
our thing at 3 p.m.
not lying but no damage I was going like 60 and they were
probably going 65 so it was just a bounce oh my god Dargo
that's really scary though That's really scary.
I'm glad you're safe.
An assistant is working on everyday chores behind his
computer.
He doesn't look too busy.
You sound a little judgmental, buddy.
Hello, I'm here for my snack.
My house husband.
Do you want lunch today?
I can throw something together.
Yes, please.
Oh good, I have manners.
ready for you in a jiffy so what exactly do you want to talk
to everyone oh my gosh heard about the murder but they don't
understand it it's a very dangerous why do we have a
sandwich to warn them properly I hope most of them are
decent enough to come no problem there Emily has made all
the arrangements I've told everyone to gather around between
1500 and 1700 great
It reminds me of a film I saw recently.
Oh.
The town is under attack by aliens.
And so the mayor calls all citizens to the town hall to warn
them.
However, seeing this, the aliens attacked the hall and wiped
them all out together.
Is that relevant, Agent York?
They came as fantastic.
They used a combination of balloons and meat sinks for
exploding heads.
Those aliens start firing their death rays and heads start
popping.
Black.
Really quite something.
You speak York.
Some of us are trying to eat here.
I know, Emily.
I'm one of them.
Well, anyway, your cooking is the best, Thomas.
Thank you.
Nope, no problem.
I know.
I'm one of them.
Anyway, Thomas, this was really delicious.
Thank you.
He's incredible.
This guy.
He's so funny.
Alrighty.
Err.
This way.
Run, run, run, run, run, run.
Run, run.
What time is it now?
Hopefully that wasted a lot of time.
Hopefully like two hours.
What movie was he talking about?
This whistling song is gonna be haunting my dreams.
Me too.
Oh, that's right, oh, oh, Mars attacks.
Oh, it's 1 p.m.
Okay, we got two hours.
Can I borrow a car?
Hello?
Police car?
Can I borrow one?
Can I borrow a car?
Can I have a car?
Thank you.
Wait, I want to do the smokes.
We'll forget about the time.
Forget about the time.
Forget about the crime.
Okay, very rare and strong brand.
What's two?
It's three!
Yippee!
Alright.
Time to go to the city hall!
Bing bong, bing bong, bing.
Luckily it's close.
Bing bong, bing, bong, bong, bong, bong, bong, bong, bong,
bong, bong, bong.
So I feel like some of the cars are faster than others.
Might just be me.
Wait, am I going the right way?
Not bad.
Maybe like this way?
Oh, not bad.
So, where shall we go next?
What do you mean, where shall we go next?
We have one place to go!
Am I going the right way?
I believe the cars actually have stats, yes.
Ming-mong, wing-mong.
They do.
Wait, that's crazy.
All right, what are we going to say at our speech?
How are we going to...
What are we going to say?
I'm nervous.
Well, we dressed in our finest suit, so I think...
And everybody takes us very seriously.
I think.
Zach is gonna give the speech Yeah, York will be like
Alright, listen up everybody Listen to my buddy Zach Wait,
am I going?
No!
Oh, cool Wait, uh Hmm
This is going entirely the wrong Wait, unless No
Uh Uh Okay, we're here.
Wait, oh, we need to go.
Oh my god, there's everybody.
Everybody's there.
Okay, we need to go back and we turn on...
Can anybody read that?
Donovan?
Donovan.
Oh my god.
Oops.
Yeah, right back at you, buddy.
All right.
Yeah, but Donovan is first.
That's where we need to turn rather than Humpty Dumpty.
All right.
This car is fast, though.
It's great.
He's such a happy guy.
I think this is where I needed to be.
I think.
I hope.
Oh, okay.
It's a little shortcut.
I'll take this as a shortcut too.
I don't think...
Actually, I don't think there's any through.
Okay.
We're doing good?
Okay, okay, cool.
I'm, like, only staring at the mini-map to make sure I'm
going the right way.
I haven't seen Dawn of it yet.
There it is!
Yippee!
Okay, we're good now.
I'm taking the shortcut.
Everybody's there and I'm late.
I'm late, you guys.
I'm late.
Everybody's there.
They're waiting for me.
Everybody's saying it.
Where is York?
Jim!
Jim isn't even here, you guys.
Another life hack.
Greenvale Community Center Mercury Theater
Speech, speech Speech, speech
What did you say?
Sorry, they cranked the song up to like 100 La la la la la
The Frequent Community Center here's wrong
We need to be late so you can burst in and say kept you
oily, huh?
Chocolate!
Zach, I haven't been on stage like this since elementary
school.
Oh, God.
He's clipping out.
He's so nervous.
His jacket is shaking.
That was a tough roll.
That was a piece of scenery.
Bright red tree.
Thank you.
All for coming today.
You know the cutscene's gonna be good when the song goes on.
Good afternoon.
I'm Special Agent Francis York Morgan.
Call me York.
Some of you are already aware by now of the tragic murder of
Anna Graham.
Ah, no.
Truly a heinous, terrible crime.
Terrible, terrible.
I've come to this town to solve the murder of this young,
beautiful girl.
And to bring the one responsible to justice.
I believe, I believe.
No one can see her badge from there.
Unfortunately, incidents like these have a tendency to
happen again.
Get off of me.
Gathered here so I can share some advice in order to
minimize the risk of further fatal incidents.
Yes.
Detective!
Special agent!
Please, stay away from any dark, dangerous, isolated places.
Direct cause of death, loss of blood.
Those of you with children.
Especially...
Please, also avoid losing any blood.
Because you could die just like her.
Avoid it going out when it is raining.
Now I've heard...
So in a town of 600 people, we got what, 20?
Oh, mimicking him.
Women should also be especially careful.
I would hate to see more victims
Oh, my favorite person just walked in Oh, it's hot Kathy
Carol Hot Carol I was so close
That's hot Carol She owns a bar Which bar?
Oh, Thomas's sister Oh, Thomas's sister Wait, could you
repeat that so as i have said avoid going outside when it is
raining young women should be especially careful report
poster board looks like something i whipped up the night
before presenting a class is true but you must all remain on
guard until we do so that's all i have to say thank you this
could have been an email it's actually This actually Could
have just been like a letter He was here He was here Oh You
What do you have something to say too Yes sir So say Mr.
Morgan When paying for our sins We must not frown The loss
of Anna was for them debt so says mr morgan
when purple fog covers our town we'll all wander in hell i
fret oh mr stewart wait mr morgan is york morgan my bad okay
wait that's it uh
sure knows how to steal thunder well then zach let's ask
some questions before all these guys leave.
Ah, yes.
The purple fog, the purple mist will cover our town.
And we will all perish.
So says Mr. Stewart.
You are all free to go.
Agent York, your words really made me think about Anna's
death again.
How could one do such a terrible thing?
I'm still in shock.
Thomas, I forgot to ask.
You don't have a tattoo on your back, do you?
Uh, tattoo?
Well, I do, actually.
But why?
What?
Now?
Here?
What do you mean you have a tattoo on your back?
Thomas?
What?
Thomas, I'm asking you here to strip on stage in front of
everybody.
Oh, thank you so much for the redirect.
Thank you for the rate.
Oh.
Well, I'm wondering who G is now, but aside from that, did
it tell you anything?
Who?
It told me that you didn't kill- Sorry, go thank you for the
gifted!
We're seeing glitch-based!
Thank you for the gifted!
Thank you.
G?
You want to see that tattoo, Zach?
A big heart with an arrow through it and love G in the
center.
I don't know when he goes.
that done but yeah thank you thank you thank you see for
grandma thomas is so sweet love g agent morgan here's your
chance to get to know some of the townsfolk don't let it go
to waste uh how do i get off the stage oh here we go oh
quite a performance mysterious very poetic try princess
thank you but i don't think many of your audience
appreciated it love george maybe how romantic mr francis
york morrow yes the purple fog appears with rain soaring and
ruining our town the evil does not drain find out why the
town is sore
I can't hear him over the music.
I actually can't hear him!
But if you, Mr. George, find the right timing to chat with
me.
That is, with Mr. Stewart.
Fruitful, you will see.
So says Mr. Stewart.
Oh my God.
You know something.
But there's some reason why you can't tell me yet.
Is that what you're trying to say?
Mr. Stewart, I don't understand.
That's a poetic rubbish, Harry, and tell us what you know.
We could force you to talk, you know.
He's like, ah, you will never hear my hint before I will
drown it out.
Mr. Francis Yorkmore.
He never addresses George.
It's crazy.
To the sides.
The omens and the premonitions.
Premonitions!
They still are fives and helpful to your investigations.
So says Mr. Stewart.
Thanks for the warning, Harry.
But don't worry.
Me and Zach, we know what we're doing.
Also, don't ask about Zach.
Quentin Richard.
Oh, what is this?
Oh, we're just taking somebody's coffee now.
Thank you very much.
Emily?
Agent York, are you finished asking questions yet?
When you're done, let me know.
We'll all get dinner.
Oh, yummy!
Yippee!
Everybody's kind of creeping me out here.
I'm not gonna lie.
Wait, there's three of the same men in a row!
No relation to the case I'd figure...
The triplets are here!
This guy's...
All three of them are sick.
Why is this so scary?
This feels like an actual horror movie with everybody just
sitting here.
Silent, staring forward.
It's so scary.
They're triplets, but they won't look at each other.
They won't even sit with each other.
Oh, Richard and Quint.
suspect we have not met who are you good evening agent agent
oh geez Brian mr.
Brian the grave keeper Brian mr.
Brian I like the retro look auditioning for little grave on
the prairie Anna what oh she was so beautiful too soon
Normal doodler.
Yeah.
So sad.
I totally agree.
That's why I'm here.
Looking for the one who did it.
Were you close to her?
Hmm.
I am so curious about York's mannerisms.
Her smile.
So warm.
Anna.
Blonde hair.
So bright.
There's a graveyard somewhere.
in town, Zach.
I'm not excited about the idea, but maybe we should at least
check it out.
Wait, what are you talking about?
That's where we slept, buddy?
Aw.
Early onset dementia.
That's why he's been talking to...
Even this place is humongous.
That's why he's been talking to Zach in his brain.
Oh, Carol!
Nice!
Wait.
Oh, nice!
We got more cigarettes, too.
My man's just hyped about green tomatoes.
Everybody, don't worry about it.
Okay, let's see.
Let's talk to Carol.
Anna was an airhead.
What do you mean?
Are you saying she was killed because she was an airhead?
Or are you saying that she was an airhead for being killed?
I'm sure she's still an airhead, even in heaven.
Or someone could just be an airhead.
Every day.
If she lost a pound, she'd be ecstatic.
Gain one, and she'd almost be in tears.
She broke many, many plates every day at the diner, and
she'd always have a smile on her face.
Always having fun.
Everyone looked at her and knew she was a cute, adorable,
loving airhead.
But they would be smiling right along with her.
I wouldn't be surprised if the angels smiled with her too.
Oh, oh.
Oh God, Anna.
Oh, God, Anna, don't look at me like that.
Ugh.
Isaac and Isaiah said that Anna was a fairy of the forest.
We have a new soundtrack, but at what cost?
We can't hear anybody again.
Oh.
It's over now.
Don't worry about it.
Hmm.
She looked like Sid.
Like Sid from...
From Ice Age.
You guys are so mean.
Who are you?
Gosh, there's so many people.
Holy hell.
Oh my god!
Is that Polly?
Oh Polly, thank god you're here.
There are so many people.
Okay, I think...
Holy heck.
Someone was throwing up over there.
My mind jumped to Sid from Toy Story.
Oh.
Oh, this is the guy we picked up the card for damn she is
hot wow um i wonder how long it will take to talk to all
these people let's start with let's just start from over
here and you know we've already met quint and richard but
quint you're here too i didn't think you were the town
meeting kind of guy a friend of mine was killed you know man
i'm not letting this one go quiet i wonder if hadn't met
them yet.
If you hadn't met them yet, what kind of conversation you
would have then?
Nothing good will come from desiring simple revenge.
Oh, come on.
I'm not that stupid.
But I'm frustrated a bit just thinking that there's nothing
I can do about it.
We each have a role, purpose in life, a raison d'etre.
Don't forget that.
I know, I know.
Raison d'etre.
Just don't preach to me.
You're sounding like my old man.
shock like a weasel in an electric chair he just made me
realize that I must be getting old a raise in debt what so
weasel in an electric chair yes pretty much but some people
are hard to get along with people problems huh I thought
city folks were used to things like that there's lots more
people in the city than there are here.
Well, that's true.
But I started simplifying things a bit.
Here's my new way of thinking.
It's simple, really.
There's only three types of people.
Criminals, victims, and investigators.
Everyone else are just vegetables.
Vegetables called other people.
You really are strange.
What?
Someone finally telling the truth.
Oh, hello!
Usha!
Yeah, I called him an NPC.
Make any progress?
Of course.
Plenty.
Tell me, Usha, when is Anna's funeral?
That's still undecided.
Sally isn't really in any condition to do it right now.
Her mother?
I don't see her here.
Anna was her sole reason for living after her husband was
deceased.
Oh, no.
She's probably huddled up at home.
vegetable you okay other people are just vegetables to me
probably take some time to pay her a visit well yes you
should and i'd appreciate it if you could too um but don't
go too hard on her okay
i'm getting sleepy are you getting closer to catching the
murderer hello again fiona good to see you here well dr
johnson told me to be here oh he said it would be important
yeah that was good he may be young but he why are we looking
at all these people's backs huh very hard-working person too
all we have to do is look at people's backs and it would be
like all we have to do is have the doctor do it all people
don't understand why he's in the autopsy room all day but i
do he's doing research to make the world a better place in
the future you know he already made a fortune in la with his
career i did not know that wow you didn't oh the doctor is a
very rich man wow he has a really big house over by the lake
oh amazing zach he must be loaded rich and young a perfect
combination but you don't get he doesn't show it that's one
of the things but does nobody notice in talking to himself
fooled if it weren't for you.
Thanks for the valuable information, Fiona.
Oh.
And I totally did not hear them talking about himself.
Or talking about him.
What?
Oh, yeah.
You never know.
Hello.
Who is this now?
Oh, my gosh.
We're meeting everybody.
Why is there a cast of like 50 people?
See, you're the FBI agent are you the the map is a hundred
bajillion miles long owner of I'm FBI special agent Francis
York Morgan call me York I'm the general oh I fought for my
country in the Vietnam War a real-life war hero so why are
you living here soldier this is my hometown after a man
returns from war there's no place to go other than his
hometown your little speech she's usually alone was that a
Right, he's literally alone.
You, imbecile.
Oh.
The raincoat killer's no myth, not mere folklore.
He knows, he knows.
It's based on actual events that happen in this town.
It is.
I'm interested.
Can you tell me more about this?
You kids today don't even know how to ask for something
right.
What?
What's wrong?
What did we say?
What offended you?
Soldier, if you want to hear more, you come to my office.
Please, pretty please.
Please, tell me, please.
He literally exudes raw power, Zach.
Despite the credibility issues, we should give him a visit.
He exudes raw power.
Calls himself a general, but isn't that a sergeant's
uniform?
Oop.
More suspects.
Oh, you're a suspect.
Everybody's a suspect.
Who are you?
Well, this is a lady that was crying on that guy.
I'm U.S.
Special Agent Francis York Morgan.
And you are?
Olivia, Nick's wife.
Anna worked at your husband's diner, right?
What kind of girl was she?
Well, she was a very hard worker.
Nick's wife.
A nice girl.
Did you ever see her acting strange?
Not really.
But there was one thing.
One thing.
Well, you see, the diner closes when it rains.
Many shops do that around here, as you might have heard.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Anyway, Anna always seemed unfocused the day after it rained
and came in late too.
It was almost as if she used up all her energy the day
before.
Come to think of it, that was really strange.
Did that legendary monster really kill her?
It wasn't a monster.
Just a criminal.
The legendary monster.
Criminal I'm going to catch and bring to justice.
Is it?
Because we've been chased around by kind of a ghost.
I will endore.
So you're Nick?
Probably.
I'm U.S.
Special Agent Francis Hill.
What are we just standing there for?
I presume you are the owner of the diner.
Are you like thinking of how to introduce yourself?
Diner owner.
I'd like to ask you a few questions about Anna Graham.
Did you notice anything strange about her prior to the
incident?
Nick?
Are you hiding something?
No, nothing.
Nick, are you being a grump?
Are you being a grumpy guy?
Are you sure?
Are you hungry, Nick?
I'm sorry, but I don't like repeating myself.
You're not you and you're hungry.
Olivia just has this, like, thousand-yard stare of it from
having to deal with this dude.
Who are you?
Wow, sick pants.
Hello?
I'm FBI special agent, Francis York Morgan.
Please, call me York.
you work Wesley owner of the gun store called panda bear I
tried to call me the gun you were closed Wesley Nick kind of
sucks was there something you want to ask me how do you make
a living running a gun store in a place like this probably
worry because there can't be that many customers worry gives
a small thing a big shadow I do gunsmith work in my shop too
oh you got the skills the customers find you all you need is
a network i hope so oh that's where i get all of my stuff
from here's what i've got wait no way oh i'm
lollipops i have this the official fbi submachine gun isn't
that the thing i have though guns are just tools for killing
people i don't like it any more than you do you've got quite
a selection here dang no wonder people come from all around
Even today, a customer paid me to go to Seattle for some
help.
I just got back.
I see.
Well, I'll be sure to visit your store sometime.
I'd like for you to take a look at my gun.
Understood.
Look forward to it.
The shop will be open again tomorrow.
It's usually open from 2,000 to 0600.
What?
See you then.
You're open in the middle of the night?
Why doesn't people just say...
Why don't they say, like, 8 p.m.?
What is going on here?
Dang, Elvis, okay.
Okay.
Yeah.
Hey there, FBI.
I'm Keith Ingram.
Convenience store owner.
It's back in the hole.
So everyone calls me.
Okay, York.
No problem, man.
Yeah, man.
Keith.
I hear you run the milk barn convenience store.
And you are close.
too rock and roll you sell raincoats there by any chance
yeah but nobody ever buys them though anyone who wears one
of them i say just ain't a rocker not a rocker that's scar
of yours now that's scar rocks this scar rocks no that's a
new one i'll drop by your store soon and let's talk then
yeah cool man rock on fbi rock on fbi who are you too,
having to deal with this guy.
Oh, he stopped.
Wife?
You're Isaac and Isaiah's mother?
Yes, I'm Lily.
Lily.
Keith's wife.
Wait, you have the two creepiest children ever.
I'm FBI special agent.
Agent York, right?
Yeah, I just heard you.
Awesome.
The handsome special agent from the big city.
The facial scar trademark.
The way he's introducing himself to everybody, as if he
hadn't just introduced himself at all in the thing, you
know?
Oh, sorry.
Zach and I consider it a kind of ritual of sorts.
I heard you like five times.
Everybody hears him say, I'm Agent York, literally all
throughout the room.
It's one of those things.
You certainly are a funny one.
What?
Is she flirting with me?
So have you noticed anything strange or out of place
recently?
Well, Betch's been taking a couple of these off from...
work, but aside from that, I heard she was in shock after
the murder.
But... You think there's something else?
Well, I took the boys along to see her today.
She's always so kind to them, and they love seeing her too,
but she took in the boys and told me to wait outside.
Something about a special secret between just the three of
them.
I just couldn't understand it.
Now, that's interesting.
Thank you, Lily.
Interesting.
Perhaps we should give Becky visit tomorrow, Zach.
Becky is the mom, right?
Anna's mom?
Polly, how are you doing?
There's no way I'm going to remember all these people.
You're quite an impressive public speaker.
Really?
Thank you, Polly.
Polly, how'd you get here?
You reminded me a little of a play I saw when I was younger.
What kind of play?
The way he's yelling at her.
I'm talking about back when this place was still called the
Mercury Theater.
was young I used to come here often with my husband God rest
his soul we come on the weekend to see the latest
shenanigans are about to happen he always pretend to be
uninterested but I could tell he was excited inside he was
just one of those kind of guys really thinking about it now
really Polly so what's your favorite play oh well I like so
many there was one in particular but I can't recall the name
anymore oh it was a very famous one too is there any point
to this oh um
no nothing one more bell that doesn't ring anymore i've
always been forgetful about what what are we talking about
oh and my husband oh my god for forgetting what we saw it's
not even funny please i want oh my god so sparkling like a
happy young you were stop asking her questions no so what's
your favorite place oh my god please we're going to have
another guest soon yeah i have to get back and get things
ready another for having to hurry away i'll see you back at
the oh damn she's fast wait what do you mean another guest
zach i think she could embarrass the toughest of the fbi's
interrogators she successfully avoided answering my question
zach amazing
What?
What are you doing, ma'am?
What are you doing?
Let's hear what this person has to say.
Okay.
Oh, no.
Please.
My pot is getting cold.
Roaming.
What?
The pot lady?
Why...
Hey, mister.
My pot is getting cold.
You are...
who what are you saying I'm Sigourney Sigourney Sigourney
Sigourney okay never heard that name before ever can you
explain the pot lady for chatting I need to hurry my pot is
getting colder oh you're useless Zach we've met all sorts
today but Sigourne Sigourney weaver I'm looking at that.
I didn't know her actress's name.
It's the one Sigourney everyone knows.
Alien Watch Along.
I love Alien.
I watch it sometimes.
Like I watch it a couple times recently because I'll watch
it on the plane.
Oh, hey, Jim.
It's a goreny.
Jim, thanks for your help in the forest.
Now I learned.
How are Isaac and Isaiah?
They're fine.
They're creepy.
They really seem to love their grandpa.
Well, I guess they do, son.
Why aren't you sitting with, like, your daughter?
I want to keep them away from the filth of the material
world as much as I can.
Dang.
Their mother agrees, which is why she lets me take care of
them so often.
The filth of the world.
The case quickly and go home.
about that scar of yours do more damage than good around
here.
What do you mean?
I guess I reek of the material world, don't I?
I have to in order to do my job.
So sorry for existing.
I don't.
I'd think the same if I was born in a place like this, Zach.
Not everybody wants to stay in a small town, though.
What if the kids grow up and they're like, we want to know
the big world and know everything, you know?
Oh, let's save the hot lady for last.
oh well i have your card i ain't got nothing to tell the
cops jack the raging bull oh he owns the gas station what
about the FBI yeah what are the rumors about the scar shut
up please give me your name i'm jack they call me raging
bull that's a manly nickname if you want why were you so
close to the mic i only talked to ben franklin you You know,
first impressions are important.
I can detain you for a few days and maybe you'll become more
fun to me.
Shut up.
Zach, this is a waste of time.
Let's go.
All right.
Who are you, hot stuff?
Hey, good looking.
Nice speech.
She looks like she's... Gina the Rose!
She looks like she's out of, like, dead or alive.
something and you are oh I'm Gina I'm married to Jack he
runs the gas station call me the rose you look pretty
revealing revealing oh this old thing oh you should see some
of my other clothes you oh now you are cool that scar really
is a turn on your husband's right there my station I'll give
you a little extra service that would be great i can't
believe how expensive gasoline is nowadays some extra
service would be great now about my current case do you have
any information on anna have you seen anything suspicious oh
i don't know do not do not attempt about the difficult stuff
okay so york is nowhere zach york is so oh that's it agent
morgan i'd like to let everyone go let's go outside okay a
lot of talking to people my goodness goodbye everybody
goodbye we watch them leave one by one okay get home safe
back in the hole yeah everybody's leaving goodbye goodbye
goodbye goodbye see you later oh you too bye goodbye
everybody goodbye boys Goodbye!
Goodbye!
Oh, that took forever!
Holy cow!
We cleared it.
Oh my gosh.
Nice.
Please let me save.
Oh, I'm just about to call it.
But we'll probably, I guess, get through whatever next
cutscene, whatever next leads.
thing they tell us to do wherever we should go.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
Well then, Agent York, do you have any plans for this?
Is that a burger?
There's so much sauce that they fell apart?
I need to contact HQ and give a progress report too.
Okay, and let's call it a date here.
I'll leave the UK so tipping isn't required.
Bill, thank you!
Isn't that so late for you?
The owner of the art gallery should be back soon.
All right, then, let's do that.
feels like it's been 10 hours but i can't look away we're
going out to eat at nick's diner wait what were we peeking
at diner that might be nice thomas is a great cook but nick
is the real deal oh she's trying to be heard over the music
you can tell a very appealing proposition zach what do you
think zach are you hungry you can always go back to the
hotel after eating dinner or go directly back to the hotel
you decide zach oh let's eat with them Zach, are you hungry?
Zach, do you want a Biggie burger?
Zach, do you want a side of fries?
Why is Zach the side?
We can't think for ourselves.
Oh, we're with...
I've been sheriff here for...
Oh, the burger!
The burger!
Long time now.
This is the worst murder I've ever seen.
Tank, he like kissed it, but didn't jump.
Our town is a little odd in some ways, but it's usually a
peaceful place.
We had our fair share of cases, but just the regular stuff.
A high school kid shoplifting from the milk barn, maybe.
Are some hot-headed kids fighting, fueled on liquor?
There's children here in this town besides Isaac and Isaiah.
What kind of cases have you dealt with in the past?
Not much different from those you've just mentioned.
Really?
In the FBI?
The case I was on until last month, well, the guy killed
seven girls in a three-month period he sawed their heads off
from the neck and took them back to his house he cleaned the
skulls up and used them as utensils in his daily life to eat
from or as a urine cup he hated women that was his way of
dealing with it oh he'd He fills skulls with ice, cola, and
rum.
And he downed in one go.
For him, that was a holy ritual.
The question of his mental state is at the pivotal point in
the court case.
This guy needs to start a podcast.
The true crime girlies would go insane over this
information.
Looking for skulls.
Well, that is wonderful.
chunk of the cast.
Do you have an idea of the fun trivia of the 30 characters
of Deadly Perpetition?
Oh, God.
I love George.
Put it away his burger.
Eight?
Hot!
Dread!
Now, let's talk about something else.
You don't want to hear anymore?
That's a shame, isn't it, Zach?
I was just about to get to the good part.
I think I use a sociopath.
I mean, you're like an elite agent who just jumped out from
a movie.
800 people!
It must look like we're just playing cops and robbers.
Ugh, I give up.
I can't compete with you.
Don't say that, Emily.
the cases you have solved are all full-fledged crimes oh my
god a crime is a crime the good part yeah what was he about
to say i wonder there is no big and small i mean there is
big and small crimes always have a criminal and a victim no
victim will ever welcome a crime no matter what its size so
fundamentally there is no difference in size if you steal an
apple york is telling that you should have the death penalty
we work day and night to preserve peace and order in this
town you understand that right
of course oh my goodness i don't view shoplifting and anna's
murder yeah i don't think you should
I never even dreamt that such a thing could ever even happen
in this town.
I keep on expecting to see Anna here in this diner, waiting
on tables.
Excuse us.
Thank God he's FBI and not a judge.
You should have made dinner a more uplifting experience.
Oh, sorry.
I kept talking about my skulls and...
Good night, then.
Oh, good night.
Okay, never mind.
Goodbye.
Oh, my God.
let's call it a night oh yeah i'm not gonna try and like
comfort or you know all right god but see you
dog your work is too funny we're still on episode one holy
hell wait we're out at night and it's raining oh that don't
seem so good
well guys uh let me find find a phone oh there's one right
over here across the street wait um oh and also some cash uh
i think i have to i have to go around the wall oh wait
there's one on the other side of the street too okay right
here where is the phone there it is well that was a another
thrilling stream of this game i don't
i don't know i i don't know but um thank you so much for the
peek i wonder what do you think zach sounds like maybe Dr.
Claw from Inspector Gadget cartoon, or maybe Elmo.
I feel like he probably sounds like the adults in Charlie
Brown.
Like a mop mop, mop, mop, mop, mop, mop, mop.
They kind of like the Imagine the Thank you for the gift.
Yes.
Well, um...
I'm...
We will continue this next time With our very I feel like
I'm scared of how long this game is going to take me to play
There's so many people But we will take you one stream at a
time This game feels endless It actually dies I got the
sense Detective York and Brent Halligan would get along
That's what I said earlier Great stream today So says Mr.
Stewart Thank you!
But I had so much fun.
I hope you guys did too.
And I'm very tired.
I feel like my social battery...
They're not even real people.
But I feel like my social battery is just kaput.
So, thank you so much, everybody, for...
For stream.
I will talk to you later.
I will haunt you later.
See you when I see you.
Next time!
Otsumiro concert!
Na'chron, thank you so much for the 10 gifted!
Try Frances!
I don't think your dono showed up yet, but thank you so much
for the dono!
Fak Nii, thank you!
Thank you so much for the number 1!
Number 1!
Otsumi-to-me-to!
Eat the nasha-aya!
Have a good day, have a good night!
Eww!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Bye-bye!
Bye bye!